THE SENATE BUDGET AND FISCAL
REVIEW SUBCOMMITTEE FOUR HEARING
WE'RE PLEASED TO HAVE YOU JOIN
US HERE TODAY- WE'RE GONNA
START OFF WELL FIRST LET ME SAY
THAT- VERY PLEASED TO BE. ON
THIS COMMITTEE AND I WANT TO
WHAT. TO BE LOOKING AT IT
MINISTRY AND- OBVIOUSLY THERE
ARE SOME SIGNIFICANT CHANGES
THAT ARE POSED IN THE BUDGET
AND HOPE TO HAVE ROBUST
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT THOSE
CHANGES AND ONE A WELCOME THE-
STAFF FROM THE ADMINISTRATION
AS WELL. TO GIVE US AN
OPPORTUNITY TO UNDERSTAND THE
THINKING OF THE GOVERNOR AND
WE'RE WHERE HE'D LIKE TO GO ON
AND ON ALL OF THIS. WE'RE
DESPITE THAT WERE IN THE MIDDLE
A- A CRISIS WITH THE CORONA
VIRUS ALONG WITH. THE REST OF
THE WORLD. CALIFORNIA CONTINUES
TO BE A ROBUST ECONOMY HAVE A
ROBUST ECONOMY AND THAT THAT'S
WITH THAT PUTS US IN A REALLY
REALLY GOOD POSITION- BUT
HAVING SAID THAT WE'RE OVERDUE
FOR A- SLOWDOWN IN THE ECONOMY
AND SO WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
WE'RE BEING AS WISE AND AS
CAREFUL AS POSSIBLE WITH PHILIP
RESOURCES. WE HAVE WILL BE SLOW
ARE PAID OUR RESIDENTS SO HAVE
YOU SAID THAT WOULD WE'RE READY
TO MOVE WITH THE A- AND WE HAVE
FOR. ON MY IT IS THE I. WE'RE
GONNA TAKE UP TOGETHER WE'RE
NOT PULL. IBM NUMBER. IS IT
NUMBER TWO TO OKAY SO WE'RE
GONNA PUSH PUSH PULL NUMBER TWO
FOR A SEPARATE VOTE IN A IN A
DISK SO PREPARE TO ENTERTAIN A
MOTION ON ISSUE ONE ISSUE
NUMBER THREE IN ISSUE NUMBER
FOUR. YEAH THAT IS TRUE OKAY
THERE IS A MOTION. SIR SECOND.
OKAY YEAH AND OKAY. AND WILL
ALLOW WE'LL CALL IS TO MAKE
SURE WE'RE ALL HERE. I LOOKED
AROUND EVERYBODY SHARE WITH THE
BIG LOOKING TO TAKE ROLE.
CABALLERO HERE NIELSEN RAZA
YEAH. AND I WANT TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS FOR THEIR
PART BEING HERE A READY TO I DO
MOVED INTO IT. SO WE DO HAVE A-
ON ITEM NUMBER ONE. THREE AND
FOUR IN THAT TO DO. PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. ZERO I NIELSEN BILL
DRAW THE LINE. OKAY MOVING ON
TO ISSUE NUMBER QUESTIONS IN
THAT'S THE KEY TRANSFER PLAN
ASSESS AB. TWO EIGHTY FIVE.
WELCOME. SCOTT MORGAN CHIEF
DEPUTY DIRECTOR WITH THE OFFICE
OF PLANNING AND RESEARCH.
CABALLERO AND SENATOR ROBB.
NIELSEN FOR HOSTING US IN. BUT
FOR THE WORKING WITH YOU AND
YOUR STAFF TO HELP WE GET THESE
A PUZZLES GROUP. ALL IS REQUEST
430-040-9000 DOLLARS FROM THE
CHEN FUND OVER THE NEXT FISCAL
YEAR THIS IS DIRECTOR. OF
COUNSEL. TO SUBMIT A REPORT THE
LEGISLATURE JANUARY THIRTY
FIRST TWENTY TWENTY TWO. TO
FIRST ASSESS HOW THE CAL
RANSPORTATION PLAN ANOTHER
TRANSPORTATION EFFORTS AND- CAN
BE. OF A STATEWIDE MULTI
TRANSPORTATION TO. AND HOW
STATE'S TRANSPORTATION HOUSING
GRANT COULD BETTER BE ALIGNED
CORD. THE BE COORDINATED. ON
THE INCLUDES BOTH FUN FOR A
LIMITED TERMS AT. ASPEN
RESEARCH CORDON THAT STUDY AND
WORK WITH A DIFFERENT ANSWER.
AND IN TRANSPORTATION CO. AND
AS WELL AS FUNDING TO HIRE A
AND- OR WORK THE USE TO DO.
RESEARCH ON A TRANSFER ASIANS
IN CAL. WELCOME TO.
ENTERTAINING QUESTIONS. YOU'RE
AWESOME YOU THANK YOU MAN TO
WELL I HAVE SO MUCH IN IS WITH
THE HIRING OF A POSITION BE
ABLE TO DO THAT I GUESS MY
QUESTIONS ARE MORE ALONG THE
LINES OF I THINK THE SECOND-
POINT THE SECOND POINT THAT
YOU'RE A SET OUT TO ASSESS THE
STATE'S TRANSPORTATION AND
HOUSING GRANT. PROGRAM THAT
KEEPS COMING THE ISSUE OF
TRANSPORTATION HOUSING KEEPS
COMING UP OVER AND OVER AND
OVER AGAIN AND I THINK FOR GOOD
REASONS IS. HOW DO WE HOW DO
WE- USE THE FACT THAT WE'RE
EXPANDING TRANSPORTATION PUBLIC
TRANSPORTATION. AND THE PARTS
OF THE STATE AND IN THE STATE
M. AND IT IT SOMEHOW IT'S
SUPPOSED TO HELP SOLVE OUR
HOUSING. ISSUES AND VICE VERSA.
SO I GUESS I'M CONCERNED THAT
ONE I WOULD ASK HOW HOW DO WE
GET THERE. AND CAN WE GET THERE
SOONER I KNOW THERE ARE REPORT
THIS CALL. THE STAFF BEING TO
BE ABLE TO DO IT BY FROM. TO
TWO SO THAT'S YEARS FROM NOW.
MEANWHILE ALL THESE DECISION
ARE BEING MADE ABOUT BILLIONS
OF DOLLARS BOTH AT THE STATE
LEVEL AT THE COUNTY LEVEL AND
LOCAL LEVELS. BILLIONS AND
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS ARE BEING
SPENT WITHOUT THIS KIND OF%
ASSESSMENT SO- I'M NOT SURE
WHAT THE QUESTION IS WHAT HOW
WOULD RAIL HOW WOULD YOU
RESPOND TO THAT CONCERT WELL I
THINK THIS BUILDS ON EXISTING
EFFORTS THAT HAVE BEEN GOING ON
THROUGH THIS DID YOU BOTH
COUNSEL FOR SEVERAL YEARS YOU
KNOW. STARTED TO HOW WE LIVE AT
ALL THE DIFFERENT DID EUROPE
ARMS HOW DO WE BETTER ALLY
THOSE THERE'S A BEEN BEEN A
BUNCH OF AFTER ON PROVIDING TO
AS ON THAT TO LOCAL. AND
LOOKING AT THE DIFFERENT HOW
CAN FIND IN THE LINE WORK
TOGETHER I THINK THE ALLEGED IN
PASSING THE OF REQUIRE THIS WAS
OKAY WE'VE DONE A LOT OF THAT
BUT LET'S WHAT ALL THAT AT DONE
OVER THE- SO WE AND THEN COME
WITH IDEAS ON HOW WE BETTER
COORDINATE THAT SO WE
COMPLETELY AGREE THAT. THINGS
NEED TO BE FASTER BUT I THINK
ALSO SO MUCH WORK IT'S BEEN
DONE THAT THAT THE LEGISLATURE
I THINK WANTED US TO ASSESS IS
ON AND PROVE THAT SO WE IS BILL
POSSIBLE THE. WHAT IS GRAY. I
DO NOT DISAGREE THAT WE NEED TO
LOOK. ABILITY ISSUES AND TO
DEAL WITH- DISPLACEMENT AND
OTHER ISSUES SO I. WHICH IS
THAT WE- AND YOU THINK IN THIS
ASSESSMENT I KNOW YOU. IT'S THE
STATE'S TRANSPORTATION AND
HOUSING GRANT PROGRAM BUT HOW
DOES THIS RELATE TO WHAT'S
GOING ON AT THE COUNTY LEVEL
REGIONAL LEVEL THERE'S LOTS OF
FUNDING GOING ON THERE AND AT
THE LOCAL LEVEL AND JUST WHAT
I'VE HEARD- READ IS THAT- AS
TWO EXAMPLES THE BART IN THE
BAY AREA AND- LA. AND SET THE
RIDERSHIP- HAS GONE DOWN. AND
YET HERE WE ARE USING THAT AS A
REASON TO BUILD MORE HOUSING.
ALONG ALONG THE TRANSIT
CORRIDORS. SO I GUESS I'M JUST
KIND OF HI. WE'RE PUTTING THIS
OFF FOR TWO YEARS IS THERE ANY
WAY OF FAST FORWARD THAT WE
COULD DO THIS QUICKER YOU'RE
ASKING FOR ONE POSITION. I
DON'T KNOW IF IT WOULD TAKE TO
POSITIONS TO DO IT SOONER- BUT-
I'M JUST SAYING I THINK THERE'S
AN- WHICH WE'RE TRYING TO
ADDRESS A HUMANITARIAN CRISIS
LITTLE HOUSING RIGHT
TRANSPORTATION. USED AS A MAJOR
COMPONENT OF HOW TO ADDRESS
THAT REZONING IN ALL OF THIS. I
FEEL LIKE WE'RE MAKING
DECISIONS WITHOUT THE BENEFIT
OF THIS INFORMATION AND THIS
ASSESSMENT I MEAN WE'RE
CERTAINLY OPEN TO REEVALUATING
NOW WE CAN FAST TRACK THIS YOU
KNOW WE'RE BASING IT OFF ON THE
ON THE STATUTORY DEADLINES- I
THINK. IS FAR AS LOOKING AT
JUST THE STATE PLAN I MEAN YOU
KNOW MY VIEWS THAT WE WANT TO
LOOK AT THE REGIONAL
TRANSPORTATION PLAN STATE PLAN
HOW THEY ALL INTER AND INTRA
AND GATHER WE HAVE A FULL. THE
DONE THE SCOPE OF WORK FOR THE
ENTIRE STUDY. POINT BUT WE CAN
CERTAINLY WORK WITH STAFF TO
FIGURE OUT OF OTHER WAYS THAT
WE CAN FAST TRACK THIS TO MAKE
IT HAPPEN QUICKER. THANK YOU
VERY GOOD I THAT BRINGS BUT
YES- SENATOR. MADAM CHAIR JUST
AN OBSERVATION AS WE AGAIN AS
I'VE REVIEWED THE BUDGET THUS
FAR AS IT PROGRESSED THERE ARE
AN AWFUL LOT OF THE LIGHTS
BEING APPLIED FOR AGENCY BY
AGENCY. AND I'M A LITTLE
CONCERNED ABOUT THE NUMBERS
THAT WE'RE BUILDING. IT'S PART
OF THE BASE AND WE HAVE TO BE
CAUTIOUS OF THE BASE BECAUSE WE
WERE ONLY PRECARIOUSLY BALANCED
AND IT DOES SEEM LIKE THERE ARE
A LOT OF- DEPARTMENT SUTTER
STAFFING UP IF YOU WILL SO MY
POINT IS GOING TO BE VERY
DISCERNING ABOUT THAT AND- RE
SEEKING THE- BEST OF
JUSTIFICATIONS. FOR THE
POSITION THAT'S JUST A GENERAL
OBSERVATION AS WE PROCEED.
THANK YOU SENATOR NIELSEN- THIS
THIS SOME ISSUE RACES I WANT
AND ONE AT. PUT A FINER POINT
ON IT BECAUSE IT I THINK CENTER
DID NIELSEN IS CORRECTED IN
REGARDS TO YOU KNOW AS WE LOOK
AT. WHERE WE'RE GONNA EXPAND
RESOURCES I THINK WE HAVE TO BE
WISE ABOUT HOW WE GROW
GOVERNMENT BUT THIS IS A LITTLE
BIT. CONCERNING BECAUSE- WHEN
GOVERNOR BROWN DID THE
REORGANIZATION HOW HOUSING AND
TRANSPORTATION WERE SEPARATED
IN SEPARATE AGENCIES AND ONE OF
THE THINGS THAT WAS. AND AS A
CONSEQUENCE- WHICH AT A
COMMITTEE THAT WAS NOT PART OF
HIS REORGANIZATION WAS
ESTABLISHED BY- LEGISLATION IT
WAS CLEAN UP LEGISLATION. AND A
COMMITTEE WAS SET UP WITH
HOUSING ALL THE HOUSING
DEPARTMENT AND THAT ALL OF THE
TRANSPORTATION DEPARTMENT'S TO
MEET ON A REGULAR BASIS. AND IT
WAS THERE THAT IT WAS
DISCOVERED THAT THERE WAS A
DISCONNECT BETWEEN THE PUBLIC
TRANSIT. PUBLIC TRANSPORTATION
CONSTRUCTION FUN BUT WHATEVER
THAT PROGRAM IS. I IT THAT WERE
GRANTED. TO TRANSPORTATION
AGENCIES. AND THE LOCAL
SURROUNDING CITY OR COUNTY THAT
CONTROL THE LAND USE OF
POLICIES THE MONEY WAS GIVEN ON
THE UNDERSTANDING THAT
INCREASED DENSITIES WOULD OCCUR
ALONG MAJOR TRANSPORTATION
ROUTES THE REASON THAT'S
IMPORTANT IS BECAUSE- IT
ENCOURAGED. EIGHT WHY VARIETY
OF INCOME LEVELS TO TAKE PUBLIC
TRANSPORTATION. AND. AND SO THE
MONEY WOULD GRANTED MOSTLY TO
BIG CITIES. AND THE LOCAL LAND
USE AUTHORITIES MOSTLY CITIES
WOULD THEN REFUSED TO UP ZONE
THE AREA- AND BECAUSE THEY WERE
PART OF THE CONTRACT THERE WAS
NO OPPORTUNITY TO CLAW BACK
MONEY THAT HAD BEEN GRANTED TO
THOSE COMMUNITIES- AND SO- SO I
JUST GET CONCERNED WITH THAT
NOW WE- WE'VE TAKEN IT OUT OF
THE PURVIEW OF THE
TRANSPORTATION IN THE HOUSE.
ENTITIES AND PUT IT IN PR IS
PARTICULAR REQUEST MMHM I'M
LOOKING AT STRATEGIC GROWTH
COUNCIL IN IN REALITY THE
STRATEGIC GROWTH COUNCIL WAS
WITH ESTABLISHED INITIALLY JUST
TO. DO FUND FUNDS TO FIND LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS TO WORK ON A
REGIONAL BASIS AND NOW WE'RE
KIND OF MOVING THINGS AWAY FROM
THE TRANSPORTATION AND HOUSING
AND MOVING THEM INTO AN ENTITY
THAT'S CONTINUING TO GROW SO I
JUST YEAH I'M I'M I'M I'M
PREPARED TO. SUPPORT THIS
RIGHT- I THINK IT NEEDS A
LITTLE BIT MORE THOUGHT BUT-
JUST IN TERMS OF THAT WHOLE
SCENARIO- AND I GET CONCERNED
BECAUSE. IT HEY DON'T THINK THE
INVESTMENT IN ANY CD HAS BEEN
MADE- THERE ARE SIGNIFICANT
VACANCIES AND THE THERE'S NO
HEAD OF THERE'S NO DIRECTOR AND
THAT'S KIND OF BEEN A
PERSISTENT ISSUE- THAT CREATES
CONCERN BECAUSE HOUSING IS OUR
NUMBER ONE ISSUE WE DON'T HAVE
A DIRECT. YEAH WE'RE HAPPY TO
WORK WITH STAFF ON ON THINGS
THAT YOU MIGHT WANT INCLUDE IN
AND THE STUDY OF THE ASSESSMENT
YOU KNOW ONE ONE. THING THAT
THEY OVER THE YEARS- PR HAS
BEEN TASK WITH IS DOING
RESEARCH AND STUDIES ON. ISSUE
AREAS THAT THEY CUT ACROSS
DIFFERENT AGENCIES AND SO I
THINK THAT MAY BE ONE REASON
WHY I WAS WAS PUT IT HEALTHCARE
IS THAT. YOU MAY GET POINTED
HOUSING TRANSFER CAN CUT ACROSS
A VARIETY OF AGENCIES
DEPARTMENTS. INSTITUTIONS IN
CALIFORNIA- AND SOMETIMES. THE
LEGISLATURE OTHERS DON'T WANT
TO GIVE. A RESEARCH PROJECT
JUST TO CALTRANS OR- KELSO
BECAUSE THEN THEY MAY LOOK AT
IT IN A CERTAIN LIGHT SO. I
THINK PR IN THE IN THE PASS IS
CHOSEN TO TRY TO LOOK AT IT
FROM A BROAD. SENSE IN THAT BE
THE REASON. SLATER BUT IT W.
YEAH. A GOOD. I'M I'LL
ENTERTAIN ANY MORE QUESTIONS
THIS I WILL ENTERTAIN ON THIS
SO. MOST HAS BEEN MADE PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. CABALLERO AYE
NIELSEN NO RAZA BY. THE MOTION
PASSES TO MOVING ON TO ITEM
NUMBER ISSUE NUMBER FIVE. THE
CALIFORNIA VOLUNTEERS INFILL
INFRASTRUCTURE STRATEGY. AND IF
I COULD INVITE- MISTER FRIDAY
MR CHAVEZ. IS TAYLOR AND MISTER
WITH THE FOR. WELCOME. THIS IS
PROPOSED FOR DISCUSSION AND SO
ON YES. YOU SO MUCH FOR HAVING
US HERE TODAY MY NAME IS JOSH
FRIDAY AND THE CHIEF SERVICE
OFFICER OF CALIFORNIA
VOLUNTEERS AND I WANTED TO JUST
TAKE A QUICK MOMENT- TO SAY A
FEW WORDS BEFORE WE HAND THIS
OVER TO ANTHONY CHAVEZ ARE A
FINANCES IN ADMIN DIRECTOR-
BECAUSE THIS IS REALLY THE
FIRST TIME I HAVE A CHANCE TO
COME BEFORE YOU ALL SINCE BEING
THE GOVERNOR AND AFTER HAVING
SERVED OFFICER IN THE UNITED
STATES NAVY AND HAVING WORKED
ON THE EARNED INCOME TAX
DEFERMENT IN CALIFORNIA VERY
PRIVILEGED. TO HAVE BEEN
APPOINTED BY THE GOVERNOR TO
LEAD THIS EFFORT TO REALLY
NIGHT CALIFORNIANS AROUND ST
STE AND BALANCED AND GAUGE
MEANT AT MODE THESE VALUES OUR
STATE AND CREATE OPPORTUNITIES
FOR CALIFORNIANS TO COME
TOGETHER AND IN ADDITION TO
PROMOTING THESE VALUES AND. AND
PURSUING. THE VIRGINIA AXE FOR
CIVIC ENGAGEMENT. REALLY ARE
THINKING ABOUT HOW DO WE ENGAGE
CALIFORNIANS IN TACKLING OUR
BIGGEST PROBLEMS AND TAKING
ACTION LOCALLY AND WE'VE HAD
WE'VE STARTED INVESTING IN SOME
REALLY CREATIVE WAYS THAT WE'RE
VERY EXCITED ABOUT INCLUDING
LAUNCHING WHAT AT WHAT I LIKE
TO CALL THE CALIFORNIA GI BILL
WHERE WE'VE BEEN A PROGRAM YOU
SEE MERCED IN OUSTED LA AND
OTHER UNIVERSITY HELP THOSE
STUDENTS WHO ARE WILLING TO
SERVE THEIR- THE UP FOR
COLLEGE. SCHOLARSHIP AND THIS
DEPEND IN ACT CREDIT WE'VE ALSO
RECENTLY ANNOUNCED A HISTORIC
INVESTMENT INTO THE CENTER
VALLEY TO GREAT SERVICE
OPPORTUNITIES AND LEFT OUT
COMMUNITIES WE RESPONDED TO
COMMUNITIES INCLUDING BUTTE
COUNTY- AND OTHER DISASTER
AREAS WHO ARE GOING THROUGH
RECOVERY- IN SOME VERY
INNOVATIVE WAYS SO WE'RE VERY
ENTHUSIASTIC ABOUT OVERHEAD HOW
WE NEED TO GET IS V. OF UNITED
KEY BORN IN. IN SERVICE AND
INVOLUNTARY AND MOSTLY I AND
THIS BY JUST TO SAY THAT. WITH
YOU ALL. I TO PURSUE THIS V. TO
LIFT UP COMMUNITY TO EMPOWER
PEOPLE TO TAKE ACTION IN THEIR
OWN COMMUNITIES AND LIFT EACH
OTHER UP- AND CREATE MORE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR EVERY
CALIFORNIAN TO BE ABLE TO GIVE
BACK. AND MAKE A DIFFERENCE IN
ON BEFORE YOU HEY LOOK TO
WORKING WITH YOU AND HAVE- ANY
QUESTIONS YOU WILL HAVE. VERY
GOOD THANK YOU. YOU HAVE
CHáVEZ CALIFORNIA VOLUNTEERS.
CALIFORNIA VOLUNTEERS
REQUESTING ONE POINT SEVEN FOUR
MILLION AND TEN POSITIONS IN
TWENTY TWENTY ONE AND ONE POINT
SIX NINE MILLION AND TWELVE
POSITIONS IN TWENTY ONE TWENTY
TWO AND ONGOING. WITH THE GOAL
TO EXPAND SERVICE CALIFORNIA
VOLUNTEERS DEDICATED BUILDING
OUR BEST SERVICE STRUCTURE.
WITH A STAFFING CAPACITY TO
SUPPORT FUTURE STATE AND
CONTINUED FEDERAL INVESTMENTS.
OUR OVERALL GOAL IS TO CREATE A
CULTURE OF SERVICING PURGING
CALIFORNIANS MEAN GAUGING THEIR
COMMUNITIES START HERE WITH
THIS INFRASTRUCTURE THAT'S-
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
YOU MAY HAVE ON THIS FUNDING
PROPOSAL. THE GOOD. FOR TAYLOR
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AND I
HAVE NOTHING GAP AND MOVE A
LITTLE TO NO FOR QUESTIONS FOR
YOU. GOOD HELLO I'M BRIAN
WHETHER FOR WITH LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE- WE JUST
WANTED TO NOTE THAT THIS
REQUEST EXPAND THE NUMBER OF
CALIFORNIA VOLUNTEER STAFF FROM
TWENTY FIVE TO THIRTY FIVE- IN
LAST YEAR'S BUDGET INCLUDED
TWENTY MILLION DOLLARS AND I
FUNDS FOR GRANTS TO SERVE. THE
EXPANSION OF THE AMERICAS
PROGRAMS HERE IN THE STATE. ON
THE GOVERNOR'S MADE EXPANDING
THE CALIFORNIA VOLUNTEERS FROM
PRIORITY OF THIS
ADMINISTRATION. YOU WILL WALK
AWAY THIS AGAINST YOUR OTHER
COMPETING PRIORITIES AND TO THE
EXTENT THAT EXPANDING THIS
PROGRAM DOESN'T WANT YOUR
PRIORITIES- WE SUGGEST YOU
MIGHT CONSIDER REQUIRING
ADMINISTRATION ASSISTANT CLEAR
OBJECTIVES- FOR THE PROGRAM
INTO A MEASURE ON AN ONGOING
BASIS HOW EFFECTIVE IT IS.
SUBJECT WE- GIVE. QUESTION FROM
THE- YEAH. THANK YOU FOR ALL
YOUR FRIDAY FOR ALL OF YOUR
WORK I'VE BEEN TO YOUR OFFENSE
THEY'RE QUITE EXCITING TO SEE
YOUNG PEOPLE ARE SO EXCITED TO
BE VOLUNTEERS AND TO IS
THEMSELVES- FOR THE GOOD OF
THEIR COMMUNITY I ONE QUESTION
I HAVE WITH REGARDS TO THE- THE
ADMINISTRATION'S OR GET OF TEN
THOUSAND VOLUNTEERS. WHAT DOES
THAT MEAN. HOW AND- JUST WHAT
DOES IT MEAN IN ALL ON ALL
THOSE DIFFERENT LEVELS WHICH IS
A VERY EXCITING GOAL BUT IS
THAT WITHIN THIRTY YEARS WITH
THAT IN TWO YEARS WHAT ARE WE
LOOKING AT HERE AND WHAT'S THE
PROGRAM TO GET THERE. EXCELLENT
SO- GOVERNOR DO SOME HAS MADE
THE COMMITMENT TO GET THE
AMERICORPS PROGRAM SPECIFICALLY
TO TEN THOUSAND VOLUNTEERS
THEIR NUMBER OF FACTORS THAT
PLAY INTO THAT OBVIOUSLY THE
GENERAL FUND AVAILABILITY OF
FEDERAL FUNDS- AND DEVELOPMENT
OF LOCAL PARTNERSHIPS PART OF
WHAT THESE- POSITIONS ARE FOR
IS TO HELP. PARTNERSHIP SO
THEIR NUMBER OF FACTORS THAT GO
INTO GETTING TO TEN THOUSAND
THAT WILL PLAY INTO HOW LONG IT
TAKES HOW MANY YEARS HOW DO WE
GET THERE- AND SO THE
ADMINISTRATION IS LOOKING AT
ALL OF THOSE THINGS AND AS WE
NOTED IN THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
SUMMARY- WE WILL BE. LIKELY
COMING OUT WITH SOME KIND OF
PROPOSAL IN THE SPRING. THEY
WILL HAVE MORE DETAIL ON ON A-
PLAN TO GET THERE BUT AT THIS
POINT WERE CONSIDERING ALL
THOSE DIFFERENT- FACTORS IN
THAT PLAN. DO YOU EXPECT IN
THAT PLAN THAT STILL BE-
REQUEST FOR ADDITIONAL. ON THE
STAFF BEING OF FROM THIS I
GUESS I'M NOT GETTING THE
CONNECTION BETWEEN- WHAT'S
BEING REQUESTED NOW AND ITS
CONNECTION TO THE GOAL AND TO
THE PLAN- IT SEEMS LIKE IT'S A
LITTLE BIT AHEAD OF ITSELF NOT
SURE HOW. HOW THIS IS GOING
FORWARD SO TWO OF THE POSITIONS
THAT ARE REQUESTED IN THIS PCP
OR SPECIFICALLY IN NORTHERN IN
THE SOUTHERN RECRUITMENT
COORDINATORS FOR AMERICORPS SO
SOMEBODY IN BOTH PARTS OF THE
STATE WHO CAN HELP FIND LOCAL.
ENTITIES SO FOR AMERICORPS
MEMBERS TO PARTICIPATE THEY
HAVE TO PARTICIPATE THROUGH A
LOCAL ENTITY A NONPROFIT OR OR
SOME KIND OF PROVIDER IT'S ALSO
MAKING A LOCAL MATCH AND
HELPING TO SUPPORT THE NUMBER
IN THE VOLUNTEER EFFORTS IN.
THIS BE C. P. IN HAS THOSE
LOCAL COORDINATOR POSITION AND
SO AND SO. PART YOU SEEM TO
THOUSAND MEANS THE ABILITY TO
FIND THOSE LOCAL. THAT WILL
TAKE ON THOSE EXTRA MEMBERS AND
EXPANDING AND WHERE DO WE
EXPAND TO HOW FAR WE EXPAND
WHERE OF THOSE LOCAL PROVIDERS
CAN THEY CAN THEY WILL THEY
PROVIDE THE MATCH THOSE KINDS
OF QUESTIONS ALL HAVE TO BE
ANSWERED AND SO THAT'S THIS
PART OF THE B. C. P. THE NEXT
PART OF OUR PROPOSAL IS THEN
WHAT IS IT KIND OF MATCH THAT
WE NEED- AND FASTER WE WANT TO
GET THAT IS THE GENERAL FUND
EMPHASIS IT'LL LIKELY. BECAUSE
IT WILL TO BE CONSIDER IN THE
OVERALL. YOU KNOW IMPACT OF THE
BUDGET AND ALONG WITH
EVERYTHING ELSE BECAUSE IT WILL
REQUIRE A GENERAL FUND PIECE.
THE REQUESTED. REALLY GOOD GOOD
QUESTIONS LET ME JUST SAY THAT-
I AGREE WITH THE LA IN TERMS OF
THE- HAVING A LIST OF
OBJECTIVES AND THEN IF YOU
COULD- ARTICULATE THE GROWTH
OPPORTUNITY OF THE PROGRAM AT.
IF IT'S TEN YEARS IT'S YOU KNOW
X. NUMBER OF PARTICIPANTS- A
YEAR. AND THIS IS THE COST THE
OF THIS DATE. AS PART OF THAT
OBLIGATION AND THEN HERE'S WHAT
WE ARE WE'D HAVE TO RAISE FROM
OUR PARTNERS JUST SO WE CAN
KIND OF GET A ROAD MAP. HOW
THAT WOULD WORK I THOUGHT IT
WAS REALLY SNEAKY BRINGING IN
THE VOLUNTEERS YESTERDAY
BECAUSE THEY WERE AMAZING I
JUST HAVE TO SAY THEY WERE THEY
WERE AMAZING AND WHAT WAS
EXCITING TO ME ABOUT IT IS
I'VE- I'VE BEEN AROUND
AMERICORPS VOLUNTEERS FOR MANY.
FOR THE MOST PART BECAUSE I DID
A LOT OF IS PREVENTION WORK AND
FOR THE MOST PART. THE
VOLUNTEERS RED CHILDREN AND
THEY HELPED IN LATER AND THE IN
THE CLASSROOM SO KINDS OF
THINGS REALLY IMPORTANT- THE
PARTICIPANTS THAT CAME TO SEE
ME WE'RE DOING ENTIRELY
DIFFERENT WORK- THEY'RE TAKING
OUT THE DEAD AND DYING TREES UP
IN THE SIERRAS- AND- THEY ARE
RECONSTRUCTING- THE
CONSERVANCY'S WALKING PATHS AND
THINGS THAT. PEOPLE USE VERY
HEAVILY OF THE STUDENTS IS VERY
INTERESTED IN. WAS INTERESTED
IN. IN. THE CLIENT ACTUALLY OF
THEM WERE AT THAT SCIENCE OF
BUT CLIMATE CHANGE AND DOING
MAP OF. OUTLETS INTO THE OCEAN
SO THAT WE KNOW WHAT THEY LOOK
LIKE AND THEN WHAT THE
POTENTIAL FOR. FOR FISH-
MIGRATION IS AN INTEREST IN
REALLY INTERESTING THINGS THAT
GET THEM ON A PATH TO EARNING A
DEGREE. OR A CERTIFICATE IN THE
END THESE THE KIDS ALL THE
YOUNG PEOPLE TELL ME WHERE THEY
STARTED FROM AND SO WAS
IMPRESSIVE. BECAUSE THEY WERE.
THE STATE- SO AS A AS UP UP. AS
A CONTROL. ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT WOULD I WOULD BE FEEL MORE
MUCH MORE COMFORTABLE ON IN THE
FUTURE IS TO KNOW HOW MANY.
STUDENTS PARTY'S PROGRAM GET
CREDITS THAT EARN CERTIFICATES
DEGREES. ON FULL TIME
EMPLOYMENT- THAT THE WORK THAT
THE STUDENTS WERE DOING. COULD
FIND WORK IN THE PRIVATE SECTOR
SO UP WORK READINESS
CERTIFICATES THINGS THAT CAN
SHOW US THAT BEFORE MAKING A-
AND INVESTMENT. IN WHAT I THINK
IS AN EDUCATIONAL PROGRAM I
THINK OF IT AS AN EDUCATIONAL
PROGRAM BUT THEY'RE ALSO DOING
WORK WITH CALTRANS IN THE
CONSERVANCY'S- THEN. THAT THAT
THAT CONNECTION WOULD BE VERY
HELPFUL IN TERMS OF MAKING THIS
A PRIORITY BECAUSE OTHERWISE
IT'S HARD THERE ARE SO MANY
OTHER NEEDS AND IN THE STATE
THAT- THAT YOU'RE GONNA BE
COMPETING AGAINST THEM. I WOULD
I WOULD. IT WORRIES ME TO HAVE
A TO THE YOU NEED GOALS BUT TEN
THOUSAND IS HOW MUCH BIGGER
THAN WHAT WE ARE RIGHT NOW AND
JUST TO KNOW- THAT IT IT AND I
MY GUESS IS IT'S PRETTY. PEOPLE
INTENSIVE IN TERMS OF-
ORGANIZING AND TRAINING AND-
AND SO CAN UNDERSTANDING THAT
RELATIONSHIP WOULD BE REALLY
GOOD AS WELL ABSOLUTELY YEAH.
THERE ARE NO OTHER QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH APPRECIATE
THIS IS AN INFORMATION ONLY AND
I APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY
THANK. YOU THANK YOU AND I'M
GLAD TO HEAR THAT THEY'LL BE
SOME MORE DETAIL. FOR ME MAKE
IT A LOT EASIER. HEY MOVING ON
TO- ISSUE NUMBER SIX THE CAP
AND TRADE EXPENDITURE PLAN
CLIMATE RESILIENT RESEARCH
REGIONAL COLLABORATION
IMPLEMENTATION. WE GET TAKING
MEMBERS FOR HAVING US HERE
TODAY- I HAVE KNOWN TURKEY WAS
DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF CLIENT-
JONES AT OPR AND JUST GIVE
WENDY WHO'S THE DEPUTY IT'S
CHANGE GROWTH COUNCIL THAT THE
OKAY SEND HELP ANSWER QUESTIONS
OKAY AS NOTED IN THE STAFF
REPORT. IN A B. C. P. THEY ALSO
PLANNING RESEARCH IN
COORDINATION AND PARTNERSHIP
WITH CALIFORNIA NATURAL
RESOURCES AGENCY THE CALIFORNIA
ENERGY COMMISSION- IS
REQUESTING TWENTY FIVE MILLION
AN ON GOING FUNDING FROM THE
GREENHOUSE GAS REDUCTION FUND
SUPPORT FOR COMPLEMENTARY
CLIMATE ADAPTATION AND
RESILIENCE OF PROGRAMS- NOON
TURKEY WILL PRESENT ON. THE OPR
AN STC ASPECTS OF THIS
PROPOSAL- AND WE'RE HAPPY TO
ENTERTAIN ANY QUESTIONS THAT
YOU MAY HAVE AND HOPEFULLY BE
ABLE ANSWER THOSE AND ANYTHING
WE CAN ANSWER WILL GET BACK TO
HIS STAFF AND- POINTS IN THE
RIGHT DIRECTION. THANK YOU
INTERNET GIVE GREAT. SO HELLO
AND CHAIR IN SEND A THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. OPPORTUNITY TO BE
HERE TODAY SO AS- SCOTT MORGAN
MENTIONED I MANY GIVE I HAVE A
HIGH LEVEL OVERVIEW OF THOSE
FOR PROGRAMS THAT ARE IN THAT
PROPOSAL IN THE BUDGET CHANGE
PROPOSAL. AND THEN THEY'RE
HAPPY TO ANSWER QUESTIONS AND
CLARIFY ANYTHING THAT WE CAN.
SO THE REQUEST FOR THE FOR
COMPLEMENTARY CLIMATE
ADAPTATION AND RESILIENCE
RELATED PROGRAMS AND OPR
INDUSTRY SEE. THE INTENT OF
THESE PROGRAMS AND THIS
PROPOSAL IS TO. ENHANCE LOCAL
CAPACITY ESPECIALLY IN UNDER
RESOURCE AND VULNERABLE
COMMUNITIES AND SUPPORT
INVESTMENTS IN THE FOUNDATIONAL
RESEARCH THAT'S NEEDED BOTH TO
REDUCE RISK FROM CLIMATE
CHANGE. BUT ALSO SUPPORT OUR
WORK TO ECHO W. TRANSITION TO A
CARBON NEUTRAL ECONOMY. SO IT'S
KIND OF TOP LINE OVERVIEW FOR
THE FOR PROGRAMS IN TERMS OF
THAT UNIFIED GOAL ACROSS. EACH
EACH OF SO THE FIRST PROGRAM IN
THE B. C. P. AND THAT WE
PROPOSED IS FUNDING FOR
CALIFORNIA'S FIFTH CLIMATE
CHANGE ASSESSMENT CALIFORNIA
HAS A COMPLETED FOR ASSESSMENTS
PREVIOUSLY OVER OF COURSE OF A
NUMBER OF YEARS. THIS FUNDING
WOULD SUPPORT THE FIFTH
ASSESSMENT WHICH WOULD SUPPORTA COLLABORATIVE MULTI AGENCY
TEAM AS SCOTT MORGAN HAD
MENTIONED ACROSS OPR THE
CALIFORNIA ENERGY COMMISSION
THE STRATEGIC GROWTH COUNCIL AS
WELL AS THE NATURAL RESOURCES
AGENCY. REALLY BUILDING OFF OF
THE HIGHLY SUCCESSFUL AND
COLLABORATIVE APPROACH THAT WE
PUT IN PLACE FOR THE FOURTH
CALIFORNIA CLIMATE CHANGE
ASSESSMENT. THE FUNDING WOULD
SUPPORT A SUITE OF PRODUCTS-
AND DELIVER BALLS WHICH WOULD
INCLUDE INVESTMENT IN
CALIFORNIA SPECIFIC CLIMATE
RESEARCH TOPICS- REALLY
ANSWERING. IN THE ANSWER SOME
OF THE MOST PRESSING QUESTIONS
THAT WE HAVE AROUND RESEARCH
QUESTIONS WE HAVE OUR OWN BUT
CHANGE IN THE STATE. IT WOULD
ALSO PROVIDE FUNDING FOR THE
FIRST TIME FOR A TRIBAL
RESEARCH KIND OF RESEARCH GRANT
PROGRAM WHICH WOULD REALLY
SERVICE SOME OLD IN. BUT ALSO
POINT- NATIONALLY REALLY
BUILDING PAST PROVIDE SIR
TRIBES IN CAL YEAH TO DO THEIR
OWN RESEARCH TRY. RESEARCH THE
OTHER CA. OF THE FUNDING FOR
THIS PROPOSAL WOULD TAKEN MEN
IN. RIDLEY CRITIC. TOOL AND
SOME OF THE TRANSLATE IT'LL
WORK THAT'S NEEDED TO MAKE THIS.
ACTIONABLE FOR DOES MAKERS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE INCLUDING
STATE AGENCIES BUT OUR LOCAL
AND PARK AS WELL TO REALLY
SEEING THE NEED NOT ONLY TO
INVEST IN THE RESEARCH BUT
MAKING SURE THAT REESE. IS FOR
HELPING. OR POLICY MAKING.
CHANGE RESEARCH PROGRAM AND SO
THIS PROGRAM WAS CREATED BROUGH
ASSEMBLY BILL ONE OH NINE AND
THIS FUNDING WHICH IS THE
REQUEST FOR FIVE MILLION FOR
THIS UPCOMING YEAR- BUT WOULD
CONTINUE THAT THAT PROGRAM AS
WELL. SO MOVING FROM THE TO
RESEARCH FOCUSED PROPOSALS TO
THAT KIND OF TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE AND PASSIVELY
BUILDING ITEMS THE THIRD PIECE
OF THE PROPOSAL WOULD PROVIDE
FIVE MILLION AB TO FUND THE
ESTABLISHMENT OF THE REGIONAL
CLIMATE COLLABORATIVE'S GRANT
PROGRAM. THE REGIONAL CLIMATE
CLEVERNESS PROGRAM AT THE
STRATEGIC GROWTH COUNCIL WAS
ESTABLISHED BROUGH SENATE BILL
AND SEVENTY TWO AND CALLS FOR
THE CREATION OF A GRANT PROGRAM
REALLY TO BUILD CAPACITY IN
UNDER RESOURCE COMMUNITIES. TO
ACCESS THE FUNDING AND
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE THAT'S
NECESSARY TO DRIVE TOWARDS
CLIMATE THERE TO ADDRESS
CLIMATE IMPACTS AND MITIGATE
FUTURE RISK AND ALSO- WORK ON
CLIMATE MITIGATION EFFORTS. SO
THE FUNDING WOULD ENABLE THE
STRATEGIC COUNCIL TO MEET THE
STATUTORY REQUIREMENTS BY
PROVIDING THIS GRANT PROGRAM TO
COMMUNITIES. THE FOURTH AND
FINAL KEYS TO THE PROPOSAL- IN
IS ALSO FOCUSED ON SOME OF THE
CAPACITY BUILDING AND TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE THAT WE HAVE. BEEN
HEARING LOUD AND CLEAR
ESPECIALLY FROM OUR LOCAL
PARTNERS- AND IT WOULD FIND-
EXPANDED CAPACITY AT THE OUR OR
OUR INTEGRATED CLIMATE
ADAPTATION AND RESILIENCY
PROGRAM WHICH WAS ALSO
ESTABLISHED THROUGH LEGISLATION
THROUGH SENATE BILL TWO FORTY
SIX. TO THE FUNDING THAT WE
REQUESTED FOR THIS PROGRAM
WOULD REALLY- RESPOND TO A NEED
THAT WE'VE HEARD FROM MORE
STRUCTURED REGIONAL
COLLABORATION BETWEEN REGIONS
REGIONS ACROSS THE STATE AND
OURS AND THE STATE AGENCIES-
ESPECIALLY AROUND ADAPTATION.
AND IT WOULD ALSO PROVIDE-
FOUNDATIONAL FUNDING FOR SOME
OF THE FOUNDATIONAL TECHNICAL
INFORMATION AND RESOURCES AND
ASSISTANCE THAT LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS ESPECIALLY NEED TO
BE ABLE TO START. PLANNING FOR
IN IMPLEMENTING CLIMATE
ADAPTATION AND RESILIENCE
EFFORTS TO SOME OF THAT WOULD
INCLUDE FUNDING TO HELP ENHANCE
OUR EXISTING REQUIREMENTS TO
IMPLEMENT THE ADAPTATION
CLEARING HOUSE SPECIFICALLY WE
HAVE HEARD THE CALL FOR THE NAY
NEED FOR ADDITIONAL.
INFORMATION AND TOOLS TO HELP
IDENTIFY VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES
ACROSS THE STATE THAT CAN HELP
INFORM FUNDING AND POLICY
DECISIONS BOTH STATE AND
LOCALLY LEAD AND THEN ALSO
FUNDING TO SUPPORT A SWEET-
OUTCOME BASED CLIMATE
pMETRICS THAT CAN REALLY HELP
THE STATE BETTER UNDERSTAND
WATER ARE POLLS ON RESILIENCE.
HOW DO WE TRACK AND MEASURE OUR
PROGRESS OVER TIME TOWARDS
THOUGH IT'S SOMETHING THAT WE
HAVE YOU KNOW AS A AS A GAP IN
IT. AND THAT IS THE STATE SO
THAT'S IN THE FOR THE FOR
PROGRAMS THERE'S. A LOT IN
THERE I WILL. AND IN. IT VERY
GOOD THAT ONLINE. ANY OTHER
TESTIMONY FROM THE ADMIN ON.
OKAY THE ONLY OFFICE HI BRAIN
WITH AFFORDABLE ANALYST'S ON WE
PRESENTED OUR FULL- COMMENTS ON
THIS PROPOSAL IN THE FULL
SENATE BUDGET COMMITTEE AND IT
TO SEVILLE BOWL AND- THIS TIME
BREAKING A DISTRICT THAT WE
PRODUCED OF LAST MONTH AND- AS
WELL OUR SYSTEM IS INCLUDED IN
YOUR AGENDA SO I WANT TO ADD TO
MUCH AT THIS TIME I JUST WANTED
TO KNOW IF THESE PROPOSALS
REPRESENT A SIGNIFICANT
EXPANSION. OF THE STATE'S
CLIMATE RELATED RESEARCH AND
TECHICAL ACTIVITIES AND THAT
OVERALL THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSALS A REASONABLE. HOWEVER
THE LEGISLATURE COULD TAKE A
SOMEWHAT DIFFERENT APPROACH OF
IT SHOWS- YOU GENERALLY SHOULD
CONSIDER- A PACKAGE OF
RESEARCHING TECHNICAL-
ACTIVITIES THAT YOU VIEW TO BE
YOUR HIGHEST PRIORITIES AND
INSUFFICIENTLY FUND THOSE. AND
IN ADDITION WE RECOMMEND THAT
YOU DOT STATUTORY LANGUAGE FOR
ANY HIGH PRIORITY CLIMATE
ADAPTATION ACTIVITIES TO
PROVIDE LEGISLATIVE GUIDANCE
AND GREATER ACCOUNTABILITY.
VERY GOOD THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
QUESTION MANY. LET ME GO AHEAD
AND START BECAUSE I DO HAVE
SOME SOME QUESTIONS AND SOME
CONCERNS- LET ME JUST START BY
SAYING MY UNDERSTANDING IS
THAT- THIS PARTICULAR ISSUE IS
GOING TO BE DECIDED BY SEPT TWO
SO IT'LL BE GOING TO THAT
COMMITTEE- AND- WE'RE JUST.
THIS DAYS SO I GUESS YOU CAN
IGNORE EVERYTHING I SAY. I AM
GOING TO VOTE ON THE COMMITTEE
ON THE FULL COMMITTEE OF THE
BUDGET. BUT BUT HERE'S MY
CONCERN AND I I'M I SHARE SOME
OF THE CONCERNS THAT THE- THE
LA- HAS- HAS ARTICULATED. YOU
KNOW TO A CERTAIN EXTENT I FEEL
LIKE WE'RE RESEARCHING TO
RESEARCH. AND WE'RE RESEARCHING
SOME MORE AND- WEEK WE ALREADY
KNOW WHAT WE NEED TO DO. AND
PEOPLE OUT OF THEIR CARS. AND
YET WE. SOMEHOW THINK THAT IF
WE PUT HIM IN AN ELECTRIC CAR
THAT TO BETTER THING THEM
PUTTING A MINUTE GAS POWERED
CAR WHICH IS YOU KNOW A GOOD
STEP IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION-
BUT I'LL HARP ON SOMETHING I'VE
BEEN HARPING ON FOR A REALLY
LONG TIME IS UNTIL WE START-
CREATING A ROBUST TRANSPORT BUT
TRANSPORTATION SYSTEM. THAT
EVERYBODY WANTS TO USE. NOT
JUST POOR PEOPLE BECAUSE THEY
HAVE NO CHOICE- THAT'S WHY WE
SEE THE DECLINING. RIDERSHIP
AND WE HAVEN'T. INCLUDED THE
SUBURBS OR RURAL CALIFORNIA IN
THAT TRANSPORTATION
INFRASTRUCTURE SO AS A
CONSEQUENCE- GETTING AROUND IS
READ BY PUBLIC TRANSPORTATION
IS REALLY HARD AND IN RURAL
CALIFORNIA AND- PEOPLE PAY FOR
REID'S AMONG THEIR FRIENDS READ
YOU KNOW IN ORDER TO BE ABLE TO
GET SOMEWHERE SO. I'M SO
THERE'S A COUPLE OF THINGS ONE
IS THAT THE FIFTH CLIMATE
ASSESSMENT. DOES NOT INCLUDE
CDFA AND TO ME THAT'S A HUGE
OVERSIGHT. BECAUSE IT'S A IT'S
A- IT'S A DECISION THAT. DOES
NOT RECOGNIZE. THAT OPEN SPACE
IN AG LAND AND NOT JUST OPEN
SPACE FOR OPEN SPACE BUT BE
APPROPRIATE- AT. THE LAND
MANAGEMENT OPPORTUNITIES THAT
WE HAVE COULD HELP US TO SOLVE
SOME OF OUR OUR AT GREENHOUSE
GAS ISSUES AND I SAW A
STATISTIC THEM I CAN FIGURE OUT
WHAT REPORT CAME FROM BUT THAT
WHEN YOU DO A CONVERSION OF AT
OF AG LAND OR RANGE LAND TO AN
URBANIZED USE. THAT IT. EIGHTY
TIMES THE GREENHOUSE GASES AND
SO THE MORE THAT WE CONTINUE TO
KICK EM EXPAND OUR FOOTPRINT OF
CONCRETE THAT THE MORE WE'RE
GOING TO BE CREATING PROBLEMS
AND THAT INCLUDES ROADWAYS BY
THE WAY WHICH IS WHY I AM SUCH
AN ADVOCATE FOR. PUBLIC TRANSIT
TRANSPORTATION SO I THINK. I
THINK THAT- THAT CDFA NEEDS TO
BE PART OF THAT AND I MIGHT MY
CAUTION. IN SOME OF THIS
RESEARCH I'M AND THIS IS JUST-
FROM MY PERSPECTIVE IS THAT.
THERE ARE THAT THAT WE DON'T
DECIDE WHAT THE SOLUTIONS ARE
AHEAD OF TIME AND THEN ONLY
STUDY THEM AND SAY WE'VE GOT TO
DO THEM WE LOOK AT THE FULL
RANGE OF ENERGY OPTIONS- AND-
AND UP. COMBINATIONS OF THINGS
THAT WE SHOULD BE DOING HAT
WE'RE GOING TO ASK THE PUBLIC
TO JOIN US IN I HAVE YOUNG KIDS
NOW IT IS ASKING ME WHAT DO YOU
DOING ABOUT CLIMATE CHANGE AND-
THE ANSWER TO THAT IS WHAT ARE
WHAT ARE WE DOING RIGHT. DO YOU
NEED A RIDE TO SCHOOL IN THE
MORNING OR CAN YOU JUST WALK OR
RIDE A BIKE THAT THE KINDS OF
CHANGES WE'RE GOING TO ASK
PEOPLE TO MAKE AND- YET WE
DON'T HAVE ANYTHING. THAT
INVOLVES AN EDUCATION PROCESS-
FOR YOUNG PEOPLE THAT INCLUDES
THEM IN THE DECISION MAKING.
AGES IF YOU SPEND YOUR MONEY ON
THIS IT'S GOING TO IT'S GOING
TO CREATE MORE CLIMATE CHANGE-
IF YOU'RE- THROWING YOUR TRASH
OUTSIDE THE WINDOW IT'S A IT'S-
IT'S GOING TO OUR DRAIN SYSTEMS
INTO THE OCEAN IT'S- THOSE
KINDS OF THINGS THAT TELL
PEOPLE. YOU KNOW IT IT IT WE
WOULDN'T HAVE TO RECYCLE SO
MUCH PLASTIC PEOPLE DIDN'T USE
PLASTIC RIGHT- SO I MY CONCERN
IS JUST- I AM. I'M I'M
INTERESTED IN IN MAKING SURE
THAT AGRICULTURE IS AT THE
TABLE- AND- AND THAT WE LOOK AT
NATURAL GAS AS WELL AS- HYDRO
AS WELL AS- YOU KNOW SOME OF
THE OF A BIO MASS. EIGHT YOU
KNOW THEY'RE THEY'RE THE
TECHNOLOGY'S GOTTEN BETTER OVER
TIME AND WE'VE WE'VE IGNORED IT
AND SO I SAY THIS BECAUSE I
HAVE HAD INTERNATIONAL
VISITORS. AND I HAVE TRAVELED
INTERNATIONALLY THIS YEAR. AND
I'VE OTHER COUNTRIES THAT ARE
VERY PROGRESSIVE. ARE USING ALL
OF THE AT ALL OF THESE OPTIONS
THE CALIFORNIA REFUSES TO
BECAUSE WE HAVE THIS PUSH. THAT
IT HAS TO BE IN YOU KNOW-
ELECTRIC GENERATED BY SOLAR OR
WIND AND THAT'S IT AND WE'RE
LOSING AN OPPORTUNITY FOR
ECONOMIC GROWTH IN RURAL
CALIFORNIA SO I IT IF IT THAT
NIGHT I HAVE SOME SERIOUS
CONCERNS WITH HOW THIS IS LAID
OUT IN ONE ONE. ONE FINAL
QUESTION ACTUALLY IS WHAT
OPPORTUNITIES ARE THERE FOR
LEGISLATIVE OVERSIGHT OF IF ANY
OF THAT THE- THE WORK THAT YOU
WOULD BE DOING JUST SO THAT WE
IT IT'S PRETTY FAN IN TERMS OF.
IT IS EXACTLY THE DIRECTION
THAT YOU WANT TO GO WITH SOME
OF THESE STUDIES. ARE SOME OF
THE RESEARCH AND- SO I FROM MY
PERSPECTIVE BECAUSE IT. IT IS
THEN AND I HAVE SOME. DEFINITE
FEELINGS ABOUT OUT THINGS WE
SHOULD BE LOOKING AT REAL I'M
I'M INTERESTED IN GOOD SCIENCE
NOT SIGNED SINCE BEEN COOKED
BECAUSE WE'VE DECIDED WITH THE
SOLUTIONS ARE READY AND SOME.
YEAH ME THAT DOWN THE
LEGISLATIVE INTERACTION I THINK
YOU KNOW PART OF THAT'S GOING
TO BE. THE BACK AND FORTH
BETWEEN THE LEGISLATIVE
COMMITTEES IN THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE AND WHAT THAT FINAL KIND
OF. YOU KNOW GETTING THE TRADE
EXPENDITURE PLAN LOOKS LIKE YOU
KNOW OBVIOUSLY THIS IS A SMALL
PART OF THAT- SO YOU KNOW. I
CAN'T SPEAK ON BEHALF OF THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE THEMSELVES
BUT I'M SURE IT IS THAT THE
WILLINGNESS THEIR END CAN YOU
TO WORK WITH YOU ON ON ISSUES
THAT THAT YOU. IS THERE ALL
BALLOT ISSUES. AS AN ADJUSTABLE
INDIANA STRATEGIC PROCONSUL
ANIMAL TAMING YOU'RE SPEAKING
OUR LANGUAGE WE ARE. PASSIONATE
ABOUT THE SAME ISSUES THAT YOUR
PASSION ABOUT OUR COUNCIL.
CURRENTLY IS MADE UP OF NOT
ONLY THE CHAIR OF THE P. R. BUT
ALSO SIX CABINET SECRETARIES OF
WHICH- I'M SECRETARY ROSS IS
ONE OF THEM. AND SHE IS A
PASSIONATE ADVOCATE FOR THE
WORK THAT I SHE SEE DOES. AND
HAS PROVIDED OVERSIGHT NOT JUST
ON THE CLIMATE CHANGE RESEARCH
PROGRAM WHICH IS PART OF THIS.
HELLO BUT ALSO- A SEPARATE
PROGRAM THAT WE HAVE ON
SUSTAINABLE AGRICULTURE AND
LAND CONSERVATION WHICH IS
ACTING THE FACT ISSUES. THAT
YOU'VE BEEN ADDRESSING AND SO
ALL THE PROGRAMS ARE AS SHE SEE
ARE DESIGNED TO BE AN
INTERDISCIPLINARY AND CROSS
SECTORAL WHICH IS WHY WE HAVE.
A OVERSIGHT COMMITTEE FOR EACH
OF THE PROGRAM'S MADE UP OF
MEMBERS FROM EVERYONE OF THE
AGENCIES REPRESENTED ON OUR STC
COUNCIL. WE HOPE THAT THAT
GOVERNANCE STRUCTURE COULD HELP
LEVERAGE SOME OF THE- QUESTIONS
THAT YOU'RE ASKING ABOUT WHICH
BY NATURE ARE. AND ASKING
PEOPLE TO WORK TOGETHER- ACROSS
AGENCIES BUT IN OUR INVESTMENTS
WE ALSO ASKED LOCAL REGIONAL
COMMUNITIES TO BEGIN BREAKING
DOWN THOSE SILOS. AND WORKING
TOGETHER AND SO- AND IF YOU
WANT TO ADD SPECIFIC THE SCOPE
OF WORK WITH THE ASSESSMENT.
YEAH I MEAN I THINK ONE OF THE
JUST SECONDING THAT- YOU KNOW
YOUR COMMENT AND ALSO JESSE'S
RESPONSE HERE. THAT THE INTENT
REALLY IS TO HAVE A
COLLABORATIVE PERSPECTIVE AND
LEVERAGIN THE EXISTING
NETWORKS THROUGH THE STRATEGIC
GROWTH COUNCIL AS WELL AS- P.
OURS ROLE IN- LEADING INTER
AGENCY COORDINATION
COLLABORATION SO. THE YOU KNOW
WHERE THE PROPOSED FUNDING
WOULD GO IS NOT REFLECTIVE OF
THE INTENT OF WHO ACROSS THE
KIND OF UNIVERSE OF STATE
AGENCIES AND PERSPECTIVES WOULD
BE INVOLVED IN THE ASSESSMENT
BUT JUST. WHERE THE FUNDING
FROM OUR PERSPECTIVE WHERE THE
FUNDING COULD GO TO REALLY
ACHIEVE GOALS FOR THE
ASSESSMENT BUT WHEN PEOPLE
UNIVERSE OF WHO'S INVOLVED AND
SETTING THAT AGENDA. SO THIS
IS- YOU MENTIONED THE- A NEW
STRUCTURE IT THE STRATEGIC
GROWTH COUNCIL- IT'S OUR
EXISTING. SO WE HAVE PUBLIC
MEETINGS AND THAT ALL THE
CABINET SECRETARIES AND THREE
PUBLIC MEMBERS AS- LONG WITH A
PAIR CHAIR. AND THEY
PARTICIPATE WHERE IT'S
STAKEHOLDERS ARE ABLE TO COME
IN AND ACTUALLY VOICE THEIR
OPINIONS ABOUT GUIDELINE
PROCESS HE'S IN THE
DEVELOPMENT. BUT ALSO. AWARD ON
AND FINAL WORDS AND THE
DIRECTION THAT THEY WANT THE
COUNCIL TO GO IN. AND SO WE
HAVE A FEEDBACK PROCESS BUT ALL
OF OUR AND- BASED ON SOME OF
OUR VALUES THAT WE HAVE IT AS
YOU SEE AROUND EQUITY. WE
REALLY TAKING THE QUESTION THAT
YOU ASKED ABOUT. ARE THE VOICES
THAT ARE NOT BEING HEARD. AND
IN SOME CASES IT'S THE ROLE
COMMUNITIES THAT WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT- YOU ALSO SPOKE OF YOUNG
PEOPLE WE HAVE A- FAIRLY ROBUST
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE PROGRAM
THAT WE RUN FOR THE CLIMATE
CHANGE INVESTMENTS. AND A
NUMBER OF DIFFERENT INITIATIVES
THERE HAVE BEEN TACKLING THOSE
QUESTIONS AT THE LOCAL LEVEL
ABOUT ENGAGING ACT. NOT JUST ON
PEOPLE WHOM FORMER PROCESS BUT
DECISION MAKERS OFTEN IN THE
WHITE. COMMUNITY SHOULD LOOK
LIKE IN THE FUTURE AND SO I
THINK. WE CAN BRING ALL OF THAT
TO THE TABLE AS YOU SEE IN THIS
PARTNERSHIP. AROUND CLIMATE
CHANGE. AND IF I MAY ADD ONE
MORE- FOLLOWING ON FROM THAT
MAN ONE OF THE- THE PIECES THAT
IS IN THIS PROPOSAL FOR THE
ASSESSMENT WHICH IS DIFFERENT
THAN OR IN ADDITION TO WHAT
WAS- UNDER THROUGH THE PREVIOUS
ASSESSMENTS. IS REALLY A ROBUST
STAKEHOLDER ENGAGEMENT PROCESS
TO MAKE SURE WE'RE- PUTTING
INVEST THE STATE'S INVESTMENT
TOWARDS THE RESEARCH QUESTIONS
AND TOWARDS THE ISSUES THAT ARE
OF MOST NEED TO COMMUNITIES.
NOT JUST AYE LOAD YOU KNOW
IDEAS THAT COME THROUGH KIND OF
AND AT. THE SAME PROCESS SO THE
FUNDING AND SG SEE WOULD BE THE
LEAD TO THE FOR THAT TYPE OF
ENGAGEMENT FOR THE PAST NINE.
WOULD BE A LOT OF. NEW LAID OUT
AND TO MAKE SURE WHERE. DO IT.
I AGREE SIR THE RIGHT IS WHERE
THE PRESSING. WHITE THAT I AM.
ON MY EXPERIENCE HOW SERVED
SERVED ON THE STREET GROWTH A
THAT OKAY ARE RAN SHOW. AND
BECAUSE WE WERE CABINET MEMBERS
HAD. THE BILL TO GO WAIT A
MINUTE MAYBE WE SHOULD LOOK AT
THIS A LITTLE BIT DIFFERENTLY
SO- THE KEY IS TO HAVE THE
INPUT. AND MAKE SURE EVERYBODY
HAS A SEAT AT THE TABLE- AND SO
I JUST WANNA MAKE SURE THAT
IT'S- WHEN WE TALK ABOUT
HOUSING AND THE NEED FOR. THE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING SUSTAINABLE
GRANT PROGRAM THAT THAT. WAS
VERY DIFFICULT TO HAVE RURAL
COMMUNITIES INVOLVED BECAUSE OF
THE WAY THAT THE METRICS ARE
SET UP TO REDUCE THEM MAXIMUM
AMOUNT OF GHG YOU'RE GONNA BE
THAT'S THE BIG CITIES. AND SO I
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT THERE
ARE OPPORTUNITIES FOR US. VERY
GOOD ANY OTHER QUESTIONS.
SENATOR THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR-
I'M GLAD YOU ENDED ON THAT NOTE
BECAUSE THAT'S WHAT IT WAS
STARTING TO DEVELOP IN MY MIND
IS THE STAKEHOLDER INVOLVEMENT-
EIGHT. I DON'T KNOW MAYBE IN
BETWEEN THE NEXT NEXT TIME YOU
COME HERE- HE COULD PROVIDE OUR
OUR OFFICE WITH THE KINDS OF
ORGANIZATIONS ON THE GROUND.
ARE INVOLVED BECAUSE THAT WOULD
BE HELPFUL TO ME. TO MAKE SURE
I'M SORT OF CLOSING THE LOOP
HERE ON. THEY RAISE ISSUES TO
YOU I WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT. I
HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO MEET
WITH THEM AS WELL AND- THE P.
OR DISAGREE WHATEVER. AND BY
APPRECIATE THAT THE YOU TALK
ABOUT THE ROBUST. PROCESS AND
ENHANCE LOCAL CAPACITY THANK
YOU. THE RECOMMENDATION IS TO
HOLD THIS OPEN SO WE WILL THANK
YOU I APPRECIATE YOUR YOUR
PARTICIPATION HERE. THEY MOVING
ON THAT ISSUE NUMBER SEVEN
LEGISLATIVE AND LEGAL STAFF
INCREASE. RIGHT CITING PROPOSAL
OF FALLS SEE PACKAGE. WEST YES
PLANNING RESEARCH REQUEST THREE
HUNDRED SEVENTY FIVE THOUSAND
DOLLARS IN ONGOING FUNDING TO
ESTABLISH TWO POSITIONS TO
SUPPORT APPEARS GROWING AMOUNT
OF LEGAL AND LEGISLATIVE WORK
LEGAL LEGISLATIVE WORK WAS OR
OF ALL OF EUROPE BUDGET
PROGRAMS THAT INCLUDES STATE
PLANNING POLICY PROGRAM
CALIFORNIA VOLUNTEERS STRATEGIC
GROWTH CANCEL AND MANY OF THE
OTHER SMALLER PROGRAMS THAT
WOULD THAT WE RECEIVED OVER THE
YEARS- OCCURS BUT INSTEAD STORE
OBLIGATIONS OF INCREASE
SIGNIFICANTLY IN RECENT YEARS
FOLLOW LEGAL AND LEGISLATIVE
STAFFERS HAVE REMAINED
STAGNANT. IN ADDITION IN THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE- CONTINUES TO
YOU ASKED FOR HELP ON LEGAL
REVIEW- FOR PROGRAMS FOR SUCH
THINGS AS THE NEW ADA
COMPLIANCE IS FOR WEBSITES AND
PUBLICATIONS ETHICS AND OTHER
STATUTORY AND REGULATORY
OBLIGATIONS I JUST PHONE NUMBER
STANDPOINT AND SOME OF THOSE OF
CHANGED FROM. THE INFORMATION
THE B. C. P. WE WENT FROM ONE
PUBLIC RECORDS ACT REQUEST IN
TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN TO ELEVEN
IN TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN- WE
CURRENTLY HAVE THREE- LAWSUITS
THAT WERE NAMED IN AND- I
STARTED UP HERE WHEN I HAD A
LOT OF HERE AND PEOPLE'S WAS
GOVERNOR AND I DON'T THINK I'VE
EVER SEEN- THREE A LAWSUIT AT
THE SAME TIME- SO THAT'S THAT'S
KIND OF A NEW THING FOR US. ON
THE LEGISLATIVE FRONT TWO DOZEN
SIXTEEN WE HAD THIRTY BILLS
THAT THAT MENTIONED- P. R. OR
PROGRAMS- DIRECTLY- IN TWO
THOUSAND TWENTY WE CURRENTLY OF
SIXTY TWO- SO THAT'S DOUBLED.
ON THOSE ARE JUST BILLS AND
MENTION. US OUR PROGRAMS- AND
THEN IN ADDITION THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE ALSO ASK OUR OUR US TO
ANALYZE READY BILLS- FROM A
CONTRACTING STANDPOINT IN MANY
OF THE CONTRACTS AND AGREEMENTS
WE DO. REQUIRES SOME SOME TYPE
OF LEGAL INTERNAL REVIEW BEFORE
THEY GET IT DID YES HER SIGNED.
IN TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN FISCAL YEAR WE HAD
ABOUT FIFTY. A CONTRACT
AGREEMENTS GRANTS- CURRENTLY-
THIS FISCAL YEAR WE HAVE NINETY
SIX THAT WERE PROCESSING WITH
WITH SEVERAL MORE THAT WILL BE
COMING OUT TO CALL WE HAD. A
HUNDRED. SO AGAIN THAT'S DOUBLE
IN IN THE LAST YEAR- SO THERE'S
MORE INFORMATION IN IN IN THE
B. C. P. BUT- A FOR TIME'S SAKE
AND TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS ALL
A LEAVE IT AT THAT. ANSWERING
QUESTIONS OR CONCERNS. I KNOW.
DEALT COVERED LABELS OFFICE WE
DON'T A RECOMMENDATION ON THIS
ITEM BUT WE DO KNOW THAT PAIRS
EXPANDED UNDER THIS
ADMINISTRATION AND THE WORKLOAD
IN THESE AREAS IS RECENTLY
INCREASED AND AS NOTED IN THE
AGENDA THERE IS SOME
UNCERTAINTY REGARDING THE
ONGOING LEVEL OF WORK. ANY
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE. I
DON'T HAVE ANY WELL ACTUALLY
THE- IN TERMS OF PRD YOU A
CONTRACT WITH THE AG TO DO YOUR
LEGAL WORK OR DO YOU DO IN
HOUSE AND THEN AT AND THEN YOU
HAVE TO GO THERE THE LAWSUITS
THEMSELVES THOSE THOSE ARE
HANDLED BY THE AG OBVIOUSLY
THERE'S INTERNAL. NEED FOR
IDENTIFYING YOU KNOW EMAILS OR
THINGS LIKE DISCOVERY TYPE
ITEMS THAT WE HAVE TO DO
INTERNALLY- AND THEN WE REVIEW
ALL OF THE MATERIALS AT THE
AG'S PROPOSE AND SO THERE IS AN
INTERNAL REVIEW THAT THAT'S
DONE HAND IN HAND WITH THE
EIGHTIES OFFICE OKAY VERY GOOD
WELL THIS THE RECOMMENDATION
HERE IS TO HOLD THIS OPEN- AND
SO WE WILL DO THAT NAY PRE
SHEET THAT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THAT DATA ON THIS SERVER. THREE
TIMES. WE. GOING ON TO THE- OF
AND- HOUSING. MR FONG- THIS
CRUISE- CHRIS KIRK AND LEARNED
THIS MORNING. WELCOME THANK YOU
GOOD MORNING. SO THIS IS THE
ENFORCEMENT AND ADMINISTRATIVE
WORKLOAD. OUR STATE GOOD
MORNING MADAM CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS MY NAME IS MIKE MILLER
I'M THE DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF
ADMINISTRATIVE SERVICES WITH
THE DEPARTMENT OF FAIR
EMPLOYMENT AND HOUSING. A
REQUEST IS TO ADDRESS THE
DEPARTMENTS INCREASED
ENFORCEMENT AND ADMINISTRATIVE
WORKLOADS. THE DEPARTMENT
REQUEST SIX POINT ONE MILLION
DOLLAR GENERAL FUND IN TWENTY
TWENTY ONE. SIX POINT FOUR
MILLION ON GOING. AND THIRTY
SIX POINT SEVEN PERMANENT
POSITIONS TO PROVIDE RESOURCES
FOR INCREASING THE VOLUME OF
CIVIL RIGHTS COMPLAINTS.
ADDITIONAL LEGAL ENFORCEMENT
AND DISPUTE RESOLUTION
RESOURCES. TO ADDRESS STRATEGIC
CIVIL RIGHTS ENFORCEMENT
SYSTEMIC LITIGATION AN APPEALS.
ADDITIONAL INFORMATION
TECHNOLOGY AND ADMINISTRATIVE
RESOURCES TO SUPPORT CASE
MANAGEMENT APPLICATION.
DEVELOPMENT AND SUPPORT FOR ALL
ASPECTS OF THE FEATURES WORK.
AN INCREASE IN RESOURCES FOR
THE FAIR EMPLOYMENT AND HOUSING
COUNCIL. YOUR SUPPORT AND HERE
WITH ME AS MERRY WEEK SHE'S OUR
CHIEF DEPUTY DIRECTOR OUR HAPPY
ANSWERING QUESTIONS YOU MAY
HAVE. FINANCE NOTHING AT. HELLO
THIS MODEL IS WITH THE LA L.
THE QUESTIONS NOTED BY STAFF ON
THE AGENDA ARE REASONABLE WE
HAVE NO AT NO SPECIFIC COMMENTS
TO RATE THE THREE OF THOSE ARE
THE RIGHT QUESTIONS YOU'RE
CONSIDERING ADDITIONAL
POSITIONS FOR ANY DEPARTMENT
THANK YOU PRETTY GOOD.
COMMITTEE CENTER DRAWS THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR. I GUESS THE
WITH REGARDS TO THESE NEW FULL
TIME SLOTS WHAT IS IT HOW IS IT
THAT YOU'RE GOING TO MAKE A
DECISION AS TO WHERE THOSE
SLOTS GO- DO YOU ALREADY HAVE
THE INFORMATION I. MEAN WHAT'S
THE WHAT'S THE PROCESS TO
DETERMINE OF THE ALLOCATION OF
THAT NEW. THE STAFF. SO I MERRY
WITHIN THE CHIEF DEPUTY
DIRECTOR IN THANK YOU I'M
PRETTY QUESTIONS IN TIME- SO WE
ALREADY HAVE THE STRUCTURE IN
PLACE AND WHAT WE DO IS WE LOOK
AT OUR WORKLOAD METRICS AND WE
LOOK TO SEE WHERE THE GAPS ARE
AND WHERE THE NEED IS AN WHEN
IMPLYING THAT STRUCTURE TO OUR
NEEDS THAT'S WHERE WE DETERMINE
THE NEEDS SO WE LOOK AT YOU
KNOW THE AMOUNT OF
INVESTIGATIVE TIME VERSUS THE
MAN LEGAL TIME. WHAT WE NEED IN
OUR SUPPORT FUNCTIONS TO
SUPPORT THOSE ACTIVITIES THAT'S
HOW WE DETERMINE THE NUMBER OF
POSITIONS IN THE CERTAIN
CATEGORIES THAT WE ASKED FOR
THEM. AND SO AND HOW DID YOU.
ARRIVE THE THIRTY SIX NEW
POSITIONS- THE STAR FROM THERE
WAS A CERTAIN NUMBER OF
WORKLOAD OR ARE YOU PROJECTING
I KNOW THIS WHERE WHERE THIS-
THERE WILL BE A NEED BECAUSE
IT'S GROWING AN INCREASING SO
MUCH. SO WHAT WE LOOK TO IS THE
CURRENT WORKLOAD THAT WE
CURRENTLY RECEIVED AS OF THE
END OF THE FISCAL YEAR AND SO
WE LOOKED AT THE NUMBER OF
COMPLAINTS THAT WE RECEIVED AND
LOOKED AT THE NUMBER OF HOURS
THAT IT WAS TAKING US TO
COMPLETE THAT AND WHAT WE
NOTICED WAS THERE IS A GAP
BETWEEN THE AMOUNT OF WORK WE
ARE CURRENTLY RECEIVING AND THE
HOURS THAT WAS TAKING TO
COMPLETE THAT WORK IN A TIMELY
MATTER- WE HAVE ONE YEAR TO
INVESTIGATE THE COMPLAINTS THE
COMMAND- BY STATUTE AND SO WE
LOOKED AT THE TIME WHEN WE
LOOKED THE AMOUNT OF TIME T
WAS TAKING TO INVESTIGATE. AND
LITIGATE THOSE CLAIMS AND IN
ORDER TO- TO BRIDGE THAT GAP IS
WHERE THE NUMBER OF POSITIONS
CAME FROM BUT WHAT WERE YOU
FIGHTING IN TERMS OF WHAT GAP
WAS THE LENGTH OF TIME IT'S THE
VOLUME IT'S THE SHEER VOLUME OF
COMPLAINTS- WE'VE BEEN MEASURE
THE INCOMING NUMBER OF
COMPLAINTS AND THEN MEASURING
THE AND PROCESSING OF THOSE
COMPLAINTS- AND EVERY YEAR. FOR
THE LAST TWELVE SINCE LIKE TWO
THOUSAND AND FOURTEEN IT'S BEEN
INCREASING INCREASING
INCREASING. ESPECIALLY IN THE
LAST THREE YEARS WE'VE NOTICED
A CONSIDERABLE AMOUNT OF GROWTH
IN THE NUMBER OF COMPLAINTS
THAT HAVE COME IN. SO IT'S AT
THE NUMBER OF COMPLAINTS- AND
THE LENGTH OF TIME TO
INVESTIGATE OR IS IT. IT'S THE
NUMBER OF COMPLAINTS THAT COME
IN AND MEASURING THAT AGAINST
THE LENGTH OF TIME THAT WE NEED
TO COMPLETE ALL OF THOSE
COMPLAINTS WITHIN THE ONE YEAR
STATUTE. THAT WERE UP AGAINST
AND SO IN ORDER FOR US TO
COMPLETE THOSE INVESTIGATIONS
IN A TIMELY MATTER STATE- ARE
NOT OUT OF STATUTE. WE LOOK
WEAK COMPARED AGAINST THE
WORKLOAD VOLUME THAT WE
CURRENTLY HAVE NO PROJECTIONS
FOR THIS PARTICULAR. BASICALLY
WHAT HAVE WHAT PARTS OF THE
STATE HAVE YOU FOUND. THERE
ISN'T IN THE SEVENTIES THANK.
PARTS OF THIS. SO WE MEASURE IT
THE NUMBER OF COMPLAINTS THE
COMMAND BY COUNTY OF THE
COMPLAINANT AND OUR HIGHEST
VOLUME OF COMPLAINTS OR LOS
ANGELES LOS ANGELES COUNTY- SO
THAT HAS INCREASED ITS KIND OF
PROPORTIONAL- TO THE HIGH
DENSITY POPULATIONS IN
CALIFORNIA SO WE NOTICED THAT
LOS ANGELES ORANGE SAN DIEGO IN
SACRAMENTO OR HIGHEST. A
COMPLAINT LEVELS THAT HAS
BURNED PRETTY STEADY AS WE
MEASURE EAGER TO HEAR THOSE AT
THE TOP COUNTIES THAT COME IN-
WE HAVEN'T HAD A BIG SURPRISE
LIKE- YOU KNOW HUMBOLDT COUNTY
IS CERTAIN UP TO UP TO THE TOP
NOTES BUT ALWAYS BEEN THE HIGH
DENSITY POPULATION COUNTIES IN
CALIFORNIA.AND DO YOU HAVE ANY
SENSE OF I I'M I'M SURE
POPULATION HAS A LOT TO DO WITH
IT BUT DO YOU HAVE ANY SENSE OF
OTHER. REACHING OUT TO CERTAIN
PARTS OF THE STATE THAT MAYBE
AREN'T COMING TO YOU OR HOW DO
YOU DO HOW DO WE- BECAUSE
YOU'RE COULD BE CERTAIN PARTS
OF THE STATE THAT. JUST DON'T
KNOW WHERE OR HOW. WHY THEY
COULD BE MAKING. YOU KNOW THESE
COMPLAINTS THAT THIS IS
AVAILABLE TO THEM THAT YOU'RE
RESOURCES ARE AVAILABLE. DO YOU
HAVE ANY YEAH WE DO HAVE A TO A
FULL TIME EDUCATION AND
OUTREACH SPECIALIST WAS AN
ATTORNEY. AND HE HAS BEEN
STUDYING THE AREAS WHERE- WE
SEE THE MOST NEED IN GOING OUT
REACHING OUT ONE OF THE AREAS
THAT WE'VE BEEN TARGETING IS
CRIMINAL HISTORY AND JOB
APPLICATIONS. AND SENSE HE HAS
GONE OUT AND DONE OUT REACH WE
HAVE NOTICED AN INCREASE IN THE
NUMBER OF CLAIMS THAT WE'VE
RECEIVED A PEOPLE WHO HAVE BEEN
COMPLAINING ABOUT
DISCRIMINATORY PRACTICES IN.
THE HIRING PROCESS- REGARDING
CRIMINAL HISTORY. SO HE- HE'S
BEEN A REALLY GOOD JOB OUT
REACHING BUT AS THE OUTRAGEOUS
WE DO NOTICE THAT THE NUMBER
OF- ALLEGATIONS AND COMPLETE
ARMS. HAS HAS RISEN SLIGHTLY.
WE ALSO HAVE A- JUST REDID OUR
EXTRA WEBSITES WHAT'S MORE
ROBUST SO IT HELPED CONTAINS
ADDITIONAL INFORMATION THAT'S
AVAILABLE FOR EMPLOYERS. AND
HOUSING PROVIDERS SO THAT THEY
HAVE THE INFORMATION ONLINE- WE
HAVE A CALL CENTER THAT ANSWERS
QUESTIONS FROM THE PUBLIC. BUT
WHAT WE'VE NOTICED THE MOST IS
SINCE THE ME TOO MOVEMENT THAT
THE MEDIA FOCUS ON A
DISCRIMINATORY PRACTICES HAS
HIGHLIGHTED- BE. A AVENUE OF
COMPLAINING FILING A COMPLAINT
AND WE HAVE SEEN A SPIKE IN THE
LAST YEAR. LIKE ON GENDER.
GENDER DISCRIMINATION. AND PAY.
AND WHAT WHAT OTHER AREAS YOU
MENTIONED- WILL JUST IS JUST
BECAUSE YOU YOU DID THE OUT WE
DID THE OUTRAGE CRACKING JUSTIN
HOME GENDER ISSUES. ANYTHING
ELSE THAT'S SORT OF STANDS OUT
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT WE'RE
CURRENTLY DOING RIGHT NOW IS
OUT REACHING TO HOUSING
PROVIDERS AND- MAKING THEM
AWARE OF THE SECTION EIGHT
DISCRIMINATORY- THAT THAT THEY
COULD NOT DISCRIMINATE BASED ON
THE RECIPIENTS OF RECEIPT OF
SECTION EIGHT. FUNDING SO
THAT'S ONE OF THE AREAS THAT
WERE FOCUSING ON RIGHT NOW
TRYING TO EDUCATE THE PUBLIC ON
IT SO THAT THEY'RE MORE AWARE
THAT. AT WE ARE AN AVENUE FOR
THEM AND THAT- WE'RE REACHING
OUT TO THE PROVIDERS THEMSELVES
AND TRYING TO EDUCATE THEM SO
THAT WE CAN PREVENT THE
DISCRIMINATION ON THE FOR IN
THE- FIRST PLACE. OKAY AND- DO
YOU WORK WITH LOCAL
ORGANIZATIONS- WITH REGARDS TO
EITHER OUT RICHARD TO JUST TO.
ASSIST YOU IN IN ANYWAY HOW
DOES THAT. WE PARTNER WITH MANY
ORGANIZATIONS AS FAR AS DOING
OUTREACH WE ARE WE HAVE MADE
OURSELVES AVAILABLE FOR PUBLIC.
PUBLIC SPEAKING AND FOR BEING
AVAILABLE FOR BEING A- SUBJECT
MATTER EXPERT IF THEY HAVE A OF
BANDS WHERE IT WILL REACH A
CONCERT A NUMBER OF PEOPLE. YES
BECAUSE THE SENATOR HAS- RAISES
ISSUE- ABOUT OUR RURAL AREAS IS
WHAT HAVE YOU FOUND TO BE THE
BEST WAY. TO REACH OUT. TO
COMMUNITIES- PROBABLY- SHOULD
HAVE LOTS OF. PLANES BUT- DO
THEY HAVE ACCESS TO THE
SERVICES YES- SO WE HAVE
NOTICED THAT THERE ARE
DISCRIMINATORY PRACTICES
ESPECIALLY WHEN IT COMES TO
WORKERS THAT ARE IN ISOLATED
AREAS ARMOR- FARMWORKERS ARE
ONE OF THE AREAS THAT- YOU'VE
PROBABLY HEARD OF IT'S ALSO-
JANITORIAL SERVICES HOTEL
WORKERS THOSE KIND OF
SITUATIONS WHERE. EMPLOYEES ARE
NOT IS CONNECTED TO THE- A
WORKPLACE AND THERE WILL
WORKING REMOTELY- AND WE DO DO
EDUCATION AND OUTREACH BUT WHAT
WE FOUND IS- WHEN WE HAVE A
COMPLAINT A CERTAIN AREA WHEN
WE GO OUT AND TO WITNESS
INTERVIEWS- AND MAKE OURSELVES
AVAILABLE AND PRESENT- WITHIN A
CERTAIN POPULATION. THAT OUR
PRESENCE AND PEOPLE WILL LEARN
THAT WERE AROUND AND WERE WERE
DOING SOMETHING ABOUT IT. THANK
YOU THANK HER. IT CENTER
NIELSEN. DO YOU WITH THE WORK
FLOW SO YOU SEE YOUR GETTING
MORE COMPLAINTS. AND WHAT DO
YOU ATTRIBUTE THAT TO BETTER
COMMUNICATION TO THE PEOPLE OF
THAT THAT THE HOW TO COMPLAIN
OR WHERE TO COMPLAIN OR WHAT
WHAT DO YOU ATTRIBUTE THE
INCREASING NUMBERS. TO SO IT
HAS BEEN INCREASING A YEAR BY
YEAR AS I MENTIONED TO AND- I
THINK THAT THE MEDIA FOCUS ON-
DISCRIMINATORY PRACTICES BY
EMPLOYERS IT'S BECOME MORE.
MORE OKAY TO FILE A
DISCRIMINATION CLAIM IF YOUR IF
YOU FEEL YOU'VE BEEN
DISCRIMINATED UPON AND I THINK
PEOPLE IN THE PAST HASN'T TOLD
HIS COMFORTABLE COMING FORWARD
WITH COMING- WITH THEIR
COMPLAINT IN THEIR ALLEGATIONS
I THINK IT'S BECOME JUST MORE.
COMMON PLACE. AND AS ONE PERSON
TALKS ABOUT IT AND SAY HEY YOU
KNOW THERE'S THE DEPARTMENT OF
FAIR EMPLOYMENT AND HOUSING
THAT CAN HELP YOU IF YOU THINK
YOU'VE BEEN DISCRIMINATED UPON
ONCE ONE PERSON- COMES FORWARD
IT BECOMES A LITTLE BIT MORE
OKAY FOR THE NEXT PERSON TO
COME FORWARD I THINK THE
HOLLYWOOD FOCUS ON THE ME TOO
HAS MADE IT MUCH MORE OF
PROBABLY PEOPLE ARE HEARING
ABOUT IT PEOPLE ARE FEELING A
LITTLE BIT MORE COMFORTABLE I
WON'T SAY A 100% BUT HAS BECOME
A LITTLE BIT MORE COMFORTABLE
THEIR STORE. AND THAT THERE'S A
PLACE FOR THEM TO FIND IT
AVENUE FOR JUSTICE. WELL
THERE'S A TREND IN. WHAT SO
CALLED CRIMINAL JUSTICE REFORM
NOW THOUGH THAT. IS STIFLING
REVEALING CRIMINAL HISTORIES
THE YOU SEEN THAT DIMINISH SOME
OF THE DEMAND ON YOU BECAUSE
YOU'RE NOT SUPPOSED TO BE
LOOKING AT CRIMINAL HISTORIES
WE'VE FOUND THAT THE DEMAND HAS
INCREASED IN OUR AGENCY BECAUSE
MANY EMPLOYERS ARE NOT
FOLLOWING THE RULES THAT THEY
NEED TO FOLLOW IN THE
EMPLOYMENT PROCESS- MANY TIMES
OUR WORK IS EDUCATIONAL TO-
HELP EMPLOYERS LEARN WHAT
PROCESS THEY SHOULD BE TAKING
IN ORDER TO PROPERLY USE SCREEN
THEIR APPLICANTS AND NOT. CUT
THEM OFF BEFORE THEY'VE HAD A
CHANCE TO PROPERLY REVIEW THE
PERSON'S APPLICATION THEIR
SKILLS AND THEIR ABILITIES AND
IF THERE'S THE NEXUS IN THE
CONVICTION TO THE EMPLOYMENT
THAT THEY'RE SEEKING THEY CAN'T
JUST SAY YOU CAN'T WORK. MR SO
YOU ACTUALLY DEVOTED SO MUCH TO
THIS PROCESS TO MAKE IT CORRECT
YES WE HAVE THE STEPS AND WE
WORK TO EDUCATE AND MAKE SURE
THAT THE EMPLOYER IS. FOLLOWING
THE LAW AND THEY HAVE HAD A
DISCRIMINATORY CLAIMAGAINST
THEM ONE OF THE THINGS THAT WE
DO IS ASKTHEY HAVE TO COME TO
COMPLIANCE AND WE REVIEWED
THEIR PROGRESS AND THEIR
PROCESS- AFTER WE COME TO
HIGHLIGHT THAT THEY HAVEN'T
BEEN FOLLOWING IT OKAY AND AS
TO YOUR PROCEDURES AND
PROTOCOLS FOR PROCESSING. HAVE
YOU DONE ANYTHING THERE TO
PRIORITIZE YOUR PROCESSING OF
THESE CLAIMS AND YOU KNOW WITH
RESPECT TO BE LESSER IMPORTANT
IN THESE ARE MORE IMPORTANT SO
DO YOU. DO OUR PRIORITIZE ON
THAT BASIS OR SOME KIND OF
BASIS. FOR TO DO SO- SO WHEN
THEY COME IN WE HAVE AN
ATTORNEY THAT DOES SOME PRE
CASE GRADING ON THE CASES THEY
LOOK THROUGH THE ALLEGATIONS.
THOSE THAT I HAVE- ALLEGATIONS
OF VIOLENCE OF- YOU KNOW THAT.
OKAY THE REAL FACT IF THEY
VIOLATED THE ROUTE FACT AND
THERE'S HARM THAT THAT HAS
BEEN- ALLEGED THOSE PERCOLATE
TO THE TOP WE ALSO LOOK OUT SO
IT'S A GRADED IT AS A- THREE
STAR CASE SO THREE MEANING THE
MOST HIGHEST PRIORITY. ZERO
MEANING- NOT SO MUCH AND IT
GOES UP ACCORDINGLY- AND SO
WITH THE EYES ON EACH CASES
THAT COME IN AND THEY THEY
GRADE IT WE'VE GOT TO FIND IT
OUT TO OUR STAFF BASED ON THAT
PRIORITY PRE CASE GRADING. THAN
THE INITIAL INTERVIEW WITH THE
COMPLAINANT PROVIDES ADDITIONAL
INFORMATION TO SEE IF IT
ACTUALLY IT STAYS A THREE STAR
OR IF WE- ADJUST THAT DOWN
RIGHT AFTER THE FIRST
INTERVIEW. SO YES WE DO DO
THAT. THANK YOU SIR THANK YOU
SO IN TERMS OF YOUR INTAKE
PROCESS- IS IT DONE ONLINE IS
IT IS ALL OF THE INTAKE ONLINE
OR IS ARE CAN YOU. YOU CAN CALL
AND THEN GET SOMEBODY TO START
TAKING AN AN INTAKE FOR YOU.
THEY AND THE MOST A PREVALENT
THAT PEOPLE A COMPLAINT IS
ONLINE WE HAVE AN ONLINE PORTAL
IT'S AVAILABLE SO ABOUT- 80% OF
OUR CLAIMS COME IN OUT. OF
THROUGH THAT CHANNEL. PEOPLE
ARE ALSO TIED TO PAPER SO WE DO
HAVE A PAPER PROCESS WHERE THEY
CAN MAIL IN THEIR- THEIR INTAKE
THEIR- ALLEGATIONS TO US FOR
ALL THE DIFFERENT ALL TYPES. WE
ALSO TAKE THEM OVER THE PHONE.
SO WHAT WILL FILL IN THE FORM
FOR THEM AS WE TAKE THEIR
INTERVIEW AND- THAN THE SIGN
THEM UP. INTERVIEW DATE FOR
THEIR INTAKE SO DOES THE PORTAL
ALLOW- NON ENGLISH SPEAKERS THE
ABILITY THAT FILL OUT A FORM
YES AND. AND OR IS IT. FOR
BALLS ARE LATE IT. ACCESS THE
SERVICES AS WELL. COLD BUT I'M
MY I'M THINKING THAT THERE MAY
BE PEOPLE WHO WELL THERE ARE
WORKERS THAT WORKERS AND
TENANTS THAT DODD THEY CAN'T
READ OR WRITE WELL AND WOULD
FEEL INTIMIDATED BY TRYING TO
DO SOMETHING ONLINE. SO TO
ANSWER THE FIRST PART OF YOUR
QUESTION PORTAL IS AVAILABLE.
IN A VARIETY OF LANGUAGES SO
THEY CLICK ON A LANGUAGE BUTTON
AND OUR WHOLE WEB OR HOLE IN
STATE. INFORMATION CHANGES. THE
PAPER FORMS ARE ALSO IN I
THINK. EIGHT DIFFERENT
LANGUAGES FOR THEM TO SELECT
FROM BUT AS FAR AS THE
LITERACY- I MYSELF AND TAKE CAN
A- COMPLAINS INFORMATION
VERBALLY. AND TRANSLATED THAT
TO A FORM WE ALLOW FOR THEM TO
COME INTO OUR FOR PUBLIC
OFFICES WE HAVE FIVE. OFFICES
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA- IS SO
WILL EITHER TAKE IT VERBALLY ON
THE PHONE OR WE WILL- TO AN IN
PERSON INTAKE- IF THEY COME
INTO OUR OFFICES. OKAY AND
THEN- THIS THAT THIS FUNDING IS
SIGNIFICANTLY- YEAH IT'S LARGE
IT'S LAW I AND FOUND IT 222%
STAFFING INCREASE AND SO-
WHAT'S THE PLAN FOR FILLING
VACANT ASSUMING YOU GET-
FUNDED. WHAT'S THE PLAN FOR
FILLING THESE POSITIONS AND-
AND THE DECISION FOR WHERE
WOULD THEY GO AND WHAT KIND OF
CASES WITH THEY DO SO. THE PLAN
FOR HIRING IS OUR PLAN IS TO
ADVERTISE THE POSITIONS- AS A
PENDING BUDGET APPROVAL SO THAT
WE CAN GET A HEAD START ON IT-
THAT WAY WE CAN SCREEN THE
APPLICANTS WE FORM THE
INTERVIEWS AND THEN BRING THEM
ALL ON BOARD AS QUICKLY AS WE
POSSIBLY CAN DEPENDING OUR OUR
BUDGET APPROVAL IF THIS MOVES
FORWARD. WE HAVE A PLAN IN
PLACE FOR GROUP TRAINING FOR
INVESTIGATION AND ATTORNEY
STAFF WE HAVE ALREADY- AN
ONLINE AND A IN PERSON
TRAINING. COURSE DEVELOPED SO
THAT IS NOT NEW ITS ALREADY TO
ROLL OUT WE'VE USED IT FOR THE
LAST SEVERAL YEARS NOW- AS FAR
AS WHERE THEY'RE GOING TO GO-
THEY'RE GOING TO BE FILLED IN
THE AREAS WHERE AT THE HIGHEST
NEED AS THE LOS ANGELES.
SACRAMENTO ARE OUR HIGHEST IN
OUR IN THE BAY AREA IT'S OUR
WHERE WE PLAN ON FILLING. OKAY
AND THEN FROM THE OF THOSE FIVE
OFFICES ARE THEY ALL LOCATED IN
BIGGER URBAN CENTERS. YES YES
THEY ARE OKAY- WHAT I THINK
WOULD BE REAL HELPFUL IS JUST-
I'M A VISUAL PERSON I REALLY
APPRECIATE THAT THE COMMENTS
MADE- IN REGARDS TO- TE
INCREASE IN- THE TYPES OF CASES
THAT YOU'RE SEEING. WHAT WOULD
BE GREAT IS JUST IT. UP A GRAPH
THAT SAYS THE BILL IN THE PAST
TEN YEARS HERE'S BEEN THE
INCREASE- ARE OUT OF ORDER OR
HERE'S THE NUMBERS RIGHT- JUST
SO WE CAN GET IS A SENSE OF.
WHERE WHAT KIND OF CASES YOU'RE
YOU'VE BEEN LOOK. AND A LOT OF
THESE HAVE TO DO WITH CHANGES
IN THE LOS. AND IF NOT CHANGES
AT LEAST FROM A RECOGNITION
THAT THESE ARE NO LONGER. WELL
RECOGNITION AND THAT PUBLIC
RECOGNITION RIGHT- IN
PARTICULAR THAT- THE ME TOO
MOVEMENT- I WOULD EXPECT TO SEE
IT A SPIKE IN. IN CONCERN AND
QUESTIONS AND DATA QUITE
FRANKLY SO- THEN SO I
APPRECIATE THAT. ON THE
RECOMMENDATION ON THIS I
BELIEVE IS TO HOLD OVER AS WELL
SO WELL HOLD IT OPEN SO WE'LL
DO THAT AND I APPRECIATE VERY
MUCH YOUR TESTIMONY HERE TODAY.
CHECK TO SEE A ONE MORE CENTER
DRESS AS STRICT QUESTION A NEW
ISSUE WAS BROUGHT UP TO ARE SO.
OF SCHEDULING THE LENGTH OF
TIME AND THAT'S WHAT I HOPE
YOU'RE GOING TO ADDRESS THE
LENGTH OF TIME- TO SCHEDULE
PHONE CALL OF BUT THAT THE
EMPLOYER RESPONSES ARE VERBAL
SO THEY'RE NOT GIVEN IN WRITING.
OF THAT THAT HAS BECOME A BIG
ISSUE. WE WILL NOT SEND DMV H.
WON'T SEND EMPLOYER RESPONSES
AND LIGHTING. DO YOU KNOW WHAT
THAT'S ABOUT SO FINE AND
UNDERSTANDING AND LET ME JUST
MAKE SURE I UNDERSTAND WHAT THE
QUESTION IS SO- WHEN WE ACCEPT
AN ALLEGATION AND FILE A FORMAL
COMPLAINT WE SEND A LIST OF
QUESTIONS IN WRITING TO THE
RESPONDENT FOR THEM TO RESPOND
TO. AND THAT'S AFTER WE HAVE.
INTERVIEWED THE COMPLAINANT
RECEIVE THEIR INFORMATION WE
COME UP WITH A SET OF
SPECIALIZED QUESTIONS THAT WE
WANT TO ASK THE RESPONDENT- IN
THERE DAVE SOME THOSE BACK IN
WRITING TO US- SO IS THAT THAT
QUESTION THAT'S NOT PROVIDED.
CHOOSE THE PLAN ELEMENT THAT
THE IT'S ONLY PROVIDER VERBALLY.
THAT IS CORRECT WE DO TELL THE
WE DON'T SHARE ALL THE DETAILS
OF THE RESPONDENTS- ANSWERS TO
THE COMPLAINANT. CAN YOU.
EXPLAIN WHY I'M GONNA HAVE TO
GET BACK TO WORK OUT BECAUSE I
THINK THERE WAS SOME LEGAL-
SPECIFICS IN WHAT WE CAN AND
CAN'T PROVIDE TO THE
COMPLAINANT ON THE INFORMATION
THAT WE RECEIVED FROM THE
RESPONDENT SO IF I CAN GET BACK
TO YOU ON THAT I'D APPRECIATE
IT. OKAY THANK YOU THANK YOU.
VERY GOOD THANK YOU VERY MUCH
WE'RE GOING TO HOLD THIS ONE
RIGHT HERE THANK YOU VERY WORK.
AND THANK YOU FOR THAT QUESTION.
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE ON TO ISSUE
NUMBER NINE WHICH IS THE UPDATE
ON IMPLEMENTATION OF REGION
RECENT LEGISLATION AND OTHER
ADMINISTRATIVE ISSUES.
WELCOME
TO OKAY. FORTY MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY
NAME IS RUSS FONG OF THE DEPUTY
RECTOR FOR ADMINISTRATION FOR
THE HOUSING AND COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT- THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME TODAY TO GIVE US LET US TO
GIVE AN UPDATE ON WHAT'S GOING
ON WITH OUR DEPARTMENT
INSPECTION ADMINISTRATIVE SITE
ON MY LEFT I HAVE JENNIFER
SEGER SHE'S OUR DEPUTY DIRECTOR
FOR THE DIVISION OF FINANCIAL
ASSISTANCE AND SHOULD BE
COVERING ARE NOTICE OF MANTA
AVAILABILITY WE SEQUENCING. AND
TODAY I'M GONNA START OFF WITH
OUR VACANCY RATE SOME OF
IMPROVEMENTS WE'VE MADE IN
RELATIVELY SHORT PERIOD OF TIME
THAT I LIKE TO START VERY GOOD.
AND PLEASE DO. FIRST I WANTED
TO PAINT A PICTURE OF OUR
VACANCY RATE AND KIND OF WHY
WE'RE HERE- I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT TO LOOK AT KIND OF
THE RAPID GROWTH THAT IT
DEPARTMENTS HAD. OVER THE
RELATIVELY SHORT PERIOD OF TIME
SO IF YOU TAKE A LOOK AT THE
FIVE YEAR. I'M GROWTH PERIOD WE
HAD ACCELERATED RATE OF GROWTH
ON BOTH POSITIONS BUT ALSO
FINDING. OUT WE WENT FROM FIVE
HUNDRED AND FIFTY EIGHT
POSITIONS FIVE YEARS AGO TWO
EIGHT HUNDRED AND FORTY TWO
WHICH REPRESENTS A FIFTY. 51%
INCREASE. JUST POSITIONS ALONE.
OUR FIRST YEAR WE HAD ABOUT A-
60% INCREASE 23% INCREASE WHEN
UP 224% 4% SO THERE'S BEEN
DRAMATIC INCREASES OVER THE
LAST FIVE YEARS. BUT DURING
THAT TIME OPPOSITE OPERATIONS
ALSO. I WE WENT FOR ABOUT
SEVENTY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS
FOR STATE OPERATIONS TO A AN
ORGANIZATION THAT'S A HUNDRED
THIRTY NINE DOLLARS- SO THAT
REPRESENTS ABOUT A 75% INCREASE
DURING THAT SAME PERIOD OF TIME.
TAKE A LOOK AT OUR OUR OVERALL
WE GIVE TO OUR CITIES AND
COUNTIES- THAT'S GROWN 71%
DURING THE SAME TIME WE WENT
FROM NINE HUNDRED AND SEVENTY
NINE MILLION. TO ONE POINT
SEVEN BILLION DOLLARS. SO YOU
TAKE A LOOK AT OUR TOTAL
BUDGET- WE WENT FROM ONE
BILLION TO ONE POINT EIGHT
BILLION DOLLARS- WHICH
REPRESENTS THE BOTTOM. SO 1%
INCREASE WITHIN THAT PERIOD OF
THE FIVE YEARS SO. I KIND OF
PAINTS A PICTURE WHERE WE ARE
AND WHILE WE'RE SITTING HERE
TODAY- I LIKE TO MOVE OR TALK A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT THE VACANCY
RATE- I JUST WANTED TO INFORM.
THE VACANCY RATE REALLY IS A
FACTOR OF TWO THINGS IT'S HOW
MANY POSITIONS YOU'RE HIRING.
BUT IT ALSO INCLUDES HOW MANY
POSITION YOU'RE LOSING FOR
VARIOUS REASONS- THOSE REASONS
COULD BE RETIREMENTS- DESKS
UNFORTUNATELY HAD A FEW FOLKS
PASSED AWAY THIS PAST YEAR-
REJECTIONS ON PROBATION SO.
LEFT STATE SERVICE OR LEFT NO
DEPARTMENT EITHER FOR LATERAL
OR PROMOTION. SO DOES INCLUDE
THAT SO WE KEEP THAT IN MIND AS
WE DO TALK ABOUT OUR VACANCY
RATES. I'M TAKE A SNAPSHOT LAST
TWO YEARS. AND IF YOU LOOK AT
FEBRUARY OF TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN TO FIT EVERY OF TWO
THOUSAND. MONEY ARE. REALLY
FLUCTUATED EARLY ON AROUND JULY
AND NUMBER TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN WE HAVE OVER 30% CAN
SEE RAY. HAS CONSISTENTLY DONE
NOW. BUT IF BACK TO DECEMBER OF
THOUSAND EIGHT. AS TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN AVERAGE DROP ABOUT TWO
FOUR HOURS. I'M WITH THE DRAW
IN THE LAST SIX MONTHS AND CAN
APPROVE THAT IF YOU LOOK AT OUR
JANUARY TWENTY VACANCY RATE
IT'S WE REPORTED. PERCENT
DISAGREEMENT ON ALL TIME LOW-
IF YOU LOOK AT FEBRUARY TWO
THOUSAND AND TWENTY. 18% AND IF
YOU LOOK AT THE STATEWIDE
AVERAGE FOR OTHER DEPARTMENTS
AS HOVERS AROUND- 12214% SO
WE'RE GETTING REALLY CLOSE- TO
WHAT I WOULD SAY THE STATEWIDE
AVERAGE RATHER DEPARTMENTS- WE
ACTUALLY HIRED ACTUALLY DURING
THIS TWO YEAR PERIOD TWO
HUNDRED NINETY NEW POSITIONS.
SO THAT'S ABOUT TWENTY FOUR NEW
POSITIONS PER MONTH- THE
CHALLENGE TO THE VACANCY RATE
THOUGH AT THAT SAME TIME WE HAD
ABOUT NINETY EIGHT POSITIONS
THAT OUR OUR INDIVIDUALS THAT
LEFT FOR VARIOUS REASONS. ALL
THE VAST MAJORITY ABOUT 70%
READ RETIREMENTS OR FOLKS AT
LEFT FOR PROMOTIONS AND OTHER
DEPARTMENTS SO WE KIND OF
BOUNCE THAT OUT BUT WE DID LIKE
I SAID A HARD A MASS AMOUNT
ABOUT TWO HUNDRED AND NINETY
FOLKS BUT WE AVERAGE ABOUT
TWENTY FOUR NEW POSITIONS A
MONTH. SWITCH OVER THE LIMIT TO
THE CHALLENGES FACED EARLIER ON
WE'RE VERY A LITTLE UNIQUE FROM
OTHER DEPARTMENTS. A ONE OF OUR
CHALLENGES IS. A CHALLENGES AT
LEAST HOW IT IMPACTS OUR
VACANCY RATE IS WE HAVE. 48% OF
OUR POSITIONS DEPARTMENT WIDE.
THAT WE CALLED DEPARTMENT
SPECIFIC CLASSIFICATIONS IN
OTHER WORDS THESE POSITIONS
ONLY EXISTS OF HOUSING
COMMITTEE DEVELOPMENT. AND SOME
OF THE CHALLENGES THERE THE
PERKS OF IT IS IT PAYS ABOUT 5%
ON AVERAGE TO ITS COUNTERPART.
I'M MORE MONEY THAN POSITIONS
OF EQUAL ABOUT EQUAL TO JOBS
BUT- DUTIES. FROM OTHER
DEPARTMENTS. BUT IT ALSO
REQUIRES HOUSING EXPERIENCE.
AND BECAUSE OF THE HOUSING
EXPERIENCE IS A LITTLE MORE
CHALLENGING TO FIND FOLKS THAT
CAN. QUALIFY FOR THOSE TYPES OF
POSITIONS. I'M ANOTHER
CHALLENGE IS WE'VE HAD-AN
UNUSUAL AMOUNT OF TRYING TO
PROMOTE. SO NOW AN INCREDIBLE
SHOULDN'T MEANS IF I AM.
AMERICA IF I'M GONNA CURRENT
AND I FOR NEXT JOB I GET THE
PROMOTE. AND WE STILL BACK FOR
MY POSITION THAT. REALLY IMPACT
THE VACANCY WE USUALLY A HEART
A LARGE AMOUNT DEPARTMENT WIDE
WE HAD ABOUT THIRTY NINE
PERCENT. OF OUR OF OUR
PROMOTIONS SO THAT TWO HUNDRED
AND NINETY HUNDRED THIRTEEN OF
ALL MORE INTERNAL PROMOTION
THAT'S QUITE A BIT. SO ALTHOUGH
WE'RE PROMOTING FOLKS IN PLACE
WHICH IS ALWAYS A GOOD THING
FOR STAFF. IT DOESN'T IMPACT OF
A RATE AS YOU'D WANTED TO. THE
OTHER PART AND IF YOU LOOK AT
JENNIFER IS VERY DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCIAL ASSISTANCE WHICH
ACTUALLY ISSUES ARE GRANTS AND
LOANS- THERE AT FORTY SEVEN
PERCENT. OR INTERNAL PROMOTIONS
SO THAT'S FIFTY FOUR PEOPLE
THAT ACTUALLY WERE PROMOTED IN
PLACE. ALTHOUGH THE KIND OF THE
CHALLENGES WHEN YOU LOOK AT HER
CONCERT. OKAY THE HOT PEOPLE
ACTUALLY BRING AN END. BUT MORE
POORLY LIKE TO. CHANGE ON SO
WHAT'S CHANGED WILL BE DONE TO
ACTUALLY REDUCE DRAKE IS HERE
AND I WOULD LIKE TO. POINT OUT
A FEW. ONE OF THEM IS
CENTRALIZED OR HR FUNDS.
BASICALLY WHAT THAT DOES IS
THINGS ONE ALLOWS THE PROBE
MANAGER TO FOCUS THEIR DATA.
THERE'S A LOT LESS FOR THEM TO
DO TODAY THAN IT WAS IN THE
PAST- SO OUR HR SHOP IS NOW
FULLY ACCOUNTABLE FOR THE
RECRUITMENT PROCESS- DOES THAT
IMPACTED APARTMENT YES- WE
IMPLEMENT THIS A BACK IN. JULY
OF TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN-
BEFORE THAT THE YEAR BEFORE.
THE AVERAGE TIME IT WOULD TAKE
FOR RECRUITMENT AND RECRUITMENT
STARTS FROM THE ORIGINAL POST
DATE. THE DATE THE EMPLOYEE
STARTS. WAS ABOUT A HUNDRED IN
NINETEEN DAYS. SO EACH FOR
EACH- RECRUITMENT TOOK ABOUT A
HUNDRED IN NINEEEN DAYS BEFORE
THE CENTRALIZATION. ST STE-
JULY OF TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN
WE REDUCE THAT TO SEVENTY FOUR
DAYS. SO THAT'S ABOUT A 38%
DECREASE. AND AS OUR HR SHOP.
GETS MORE CUSTOM TO THAT I
ANTICIPATE THAT PERCENTAGE EVEN
DROPPING MORE. SO THAT WAS BEEN
A BIG FACTOR TRYING TO GET
FOLKS ON QUICKER IS THE AMOUNT
OF TIME IT TAKES TO ACTUALLY
RECRUIT A POSITION. ANOTHER BIG
THING IS WE STREAMLINED OUR
ONBOARDING PROCESS SO ONCE WE
HAVE THE EMPLOYEE HARD HOW WE
GET THEM ON BOARD AS FAST AS
POSSIBLE. I'LL BE CREATED
WHAT'S CALLED A ONE TOUCH
PROCESS WHERE. BUT ONCE THE
ONCE HR GETS A START DATE OF A
NEW EMPLOYEE. EVERYTHING ELSE
IS TAKING CARE OF SO IN OTHER
WORDS THERE THEIR CUBICLE SPACE
THERE AND- ON. IT EQUIPMENT
PHONES CHAIRS. OFFICE SUPPLIES
EVERYTHING PHONE NUMBERS
EVERYTHING IS TAKEN CARE OF FOR
THEM SO BY THE TIME THEY HIT.
WHERE THEY ACTUALLY PHYSICALLY
STARTED HIGH HOUSING. ELEMENT
ALL THEIR SUPPLIES ARE READY TO
GO. SO IT'S ALSO MUCH AMOS IT'S
PRETTY IT'S PRETTY SELF
SUFFICIENT- BUT IT ALSO GETS
EMPLOYED TO START TO BE
EFFECTIVE FROM DAY ONE. ANOTHER
THING WE'VE DONE IS- WE HARDLY
BUT I DID BRING IN TWO HR
CONSULTANTS- BOTH. HAVE ABOUT
THE OVER SIXTY YEARS OF AGE OUR
EXPERIENCE ONE OF ALMOST THE
FORMER. DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF
CORRECTIONS AND REHABILITATION.
AND THEY'VE BEEN INSTRUMENTAL
IN TRYING TO GO IN THERE AND
KIND OF HELP US STREAMLINE OUR
CURRENT RECRUITMENT PROCESSES
AND GIVE US BETTER IDEAS ON HOW
WE CAN LOWER VACANCY RATE
WE'VE- WE DID A JOB FAIR THAT
WAS TREMENDOUSLY SUCCESSFUL-
BACK IN NOVEMBER OF TWO OF. TWO
NOVEMBER TWENTY THIRD WE HAVE
AND ALL DAY SATURDAY JOB FAIR
FROM FOUR THIRTY TO EIGHT
THIRTY- WE HAD TWENTY SOME
POSITIONS ALL IN JENNIFER'S
AREA THE KEY HOUSING POSITIONS.
AND WE HAD OVER FIVE HUNDRED
APPLICANTS AND APPLICANTS CAN
GO ONLINE TAKE THE EXAMPLE
QUALIFY. ONE HUNDRED OF THOSE.
AND OF THE HUNDRED OF THE
HUNDRED THAT WE INTERVIEWED WE
ACTUALLY ENDED UP FILLING ALL
TWENTY SEVEN POSITIONS. WE
ACTUALLY MAY TWENTY WE ACTUALLY
MAY TWENTY TENTATIVE OFFERS
TODAY OF THAT SATURDAY. SO WE
DO PLAN ON DOING ONE MORE WE
HAVE ANOTHER ONE COMING OUT
WITH A LOVE IN A KEY POSITIONS
AND JENNIFER'S AREA- BUT THAT
WAS A HUGE SUCCESS WAS A LOT OF
WORK BUT I THINK WE GOT PRETTY
GOOD. LEARNED A LOT YOU KNOW
LEARN WHAT TO DO WHAT NOT TO DO
NEXT TIME- BUT I THINK THAT'S
GONNA BE A HUGE PART OF KEEPING
OUR VACANCY RATE DOWN AS A JOB
FAIR AND IT WAS HOUSING A
HEADQUARTERS IN STOCK. ALSO WAS
PRETTY CONVENIENT THE- OTHER
THING IS JUST ADVERTISING.
WE'VE BEEN VERY AGGRESSIVE OF
THE LAST FEW MONTHS AN
ADVERTISING WE HAVE USE
LINKEDIN. ON OUR WEBSITE WHICH
AGAIN PRETTY SUCCSSFUL- WE
ACTUALLY MARKET VIEW CPS-
CONSULTING FIRM TO ACTUALLY
HELP US MARKET TO. COUNTIES AND
CITIES NON PROFITS- BANKS.
EXPRESSION THE MORTGAGE AREAS-
STAFF CURRENTLY GIVE OUT FLYERS
EVERY TIME THEY DO OUT REACH
COMMITTEE MEETINGS- EVERY TIME
WE GO OUT AND DO- ANY TYPE OUT
REACHER CONFERENCES WE DO
ADVERTISE OUR POSITIONS SO WE
DO HAVE A PRETTY AGGRESSIVE
PLAN. FOR ACTUALLY ADVERTISED.
POSITIONS THAT'S BEEN REAL
EFFECTIVELY ACTUALLY OF
EMPLOYEES THAT BELONG TO A LOT
OF. PERSONAL BLOG A LOT OF.
HOUSING RELATED. CLUBS THAT
THEY ACTUALLY HAVE A CHOICE TO.
AND WE FOUND THAT JUST HAVE AN
ARM POISE ADVERTISE. YOU KNOW
HOW. SOME OF THE- OFFICE OF
WORK IN OUR DEPARTMENT. HAS
BEEN A HUGE SUCCESS. I DON'T
FIND. WE'RE TRACKING YOU KNOW I
THINK THE KEY OF PERFORMANCES
LIKE YOU SAID EARLIER TODAY IS
WE TRACK EVERYTHING RECRUITMENT
NOW IF YOU LOVE MAKE CRITICISM
CHARTS WE HAVE PLAYED. WE KNOW
WHERE EVERY SINGLE RECRUITMENT
HAPPENING NOW AND IF THERE'S
pA MEDICATED INSTANTLY- WITHOUT
AND THEN FINALLY I WOULD SAY
WERE ADDING ACTUALLY SEE A
POSITION THAT'S OVERREACH OUR
SHOP. THAT I GET THE EXTRA
LAYER OF ATTENTION THAT THIS
DEPARTMENT WILL NEED AS IT
GROWS LARGER. WITH THAT IF- BE
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
OR IF. AND TRY TO IDENTIFY.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS JENNIFER SEEKER AND THE
ACTING DEPUTY DIRECTOR FOR THE
DIVISION OF FINANCIAL
ASSISTANCE REALLY APPRECIATE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO BE HERE
TODAY AND SPEAK TO THE RECENT
EFFORTS THAT WE'VE UNDERTAKEN
TO KIND OF STREAMLINED SOME OF
OUR INTERNAL PROCESS SEES AND
HOW THAT'S REALLY IMPACTING AND
DISTRIBUTION OF- CRITICAL
HOUSING PROGRAM FUNDS SAID
SINCE TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN THE
DEPARTMENT IS REALLY WORKED.
GRAMS WILL CONTINUING TO EXIST
TO IMPLEMENT OUR EXISTING
PROGRAMS AND PRIOR TO TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN THE
DEPARTMENT'S DIVISION OF
FINANCIAL ASSISTANCE WAS
IMPLEMENTING IT APPROXIMATELY
SEVEN PROGRAMS. AND THAT NUMBER
OF PROGRAMS HAS INCREASED TO
TWENTY TWO ACTIVE STATE AND
FEDERALLY FUNDED PROGRAMS IN
THE LAST TWO YEARS. AND THAT
REPRESENTS AN INCREASE OF ABOUT
SIX BILLION DOLLARS IN NEW
FUNDING. AS SINCE JANUARY TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN THE
DEPARTMENT HAS AWARDED
APPROXIMATELY TWO POINT TWO
BILLION DOLLARS AT STATE AND
FEDERAL HOUSING. AND COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT PROGRAM FUNDS.
HOWEVER IN OCTOBER EARLY
OCTOBER OF TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN WE DID ANNOUNCE A. FOR
THE MONTH OF OCTOBER THROUGH
DECEMBER OF TWENTY NINETEEN AND
EXCEPT FOR THOSE PROGRAMS TO RE
HAD EXTERNAL OUR PARTNERSHIP
COMMITMENTS OR AND- STRICT.
ENCUMBRANCE OR DISBURSEMENT
DEADLINES SO IMPACTED SIX OF
OUR PROGRAMS DURING THE THREE
MONTH PERIOD. AND THE DIVISION
REALLY FOCUSED ON RE
ENGINEERING OR INTERNAL PROCESS
SEES TO EFFICIENTLY MAKE AWARDS
AND DISPERSE FUNDS SO THIS
INCLUDED- VARIETY OF DIFFERENT
EFFORTS AND BUT SOME OF THOSE
INCLUDED BUSINESS PROCESS
IMPROVEMENT EFFORTS TO
STREAMLINE OUR STAND AGREEMENT.
A DEVELOPMENT AND EXECUTION
PROCESS SEES SO ONCE WE MAKE
AWARD ENSURING THAT THE
STANDARD CREAM IT'S ARE
EXECUTED OVER GETTING THE MONEY
INTO THE PROJECTS AND ON THE
STREETS TO HAVE AN IMPACT IT'S
AS SOON AS POSSIBLE. I'M WE
ALSO LOOKED AT TECHNOLOGY
SOLUTIONS FOR STREAMLINED
APPLICATION SAID MIDDLE SO ALSO
FROM A CUSTOMER SPURS
PERSPECTIVE STREAMLINING THEIR
APPLICATION PROCESS BUT ALSO
HELPING US TO ACT BY OUR
REVIEW. OF SUBMITTED DOCUMENTS
AND WE ALSO WENT THROUGH AN
ORGANIZATIONAL RESTRUCTURING
DURING THAT TIME FOR TO BETTER
ALIGN OUR EXISTING RESOURCES
WITH WORKLOAD NEED. WITH CREATE
THAN PROGRAMS IS THINGS WERE
NECESSARILY ALLOCATE OUR
RESOURCES FOR NECESSARY
ALLOCATED TO IN THE RIGHT
PLACES SO WE WORK THROUGH OUR
NATIONAL REDESIGNED ARCHER TO
BETTER ALIGN NOW. I'M THREE IS
AN EXPEDITED TREATMENT IN
HIRING MANY OF THE THINGS THAT
REST MENTIONED ARE HIRING FAIR
WAS A GREAT SUCCESS. AND THEN
WE ALSO REALLY FOCUSED ON STAFF
TRAINING AND DEVELOPMENT OF
THOSE RECENTLY AIRED FOLKS AND
WE PUTTING TOGETHER A
FORMALIZED ONBOARDING- AND
PROGRAM AND ALSO DEPLOY IN A-
AN IN HOUSE TRAINING PROGRAMS.
TO BRING NEW STAFF WHO MAY NOT
COME WITH HOUSING EXPERTISE
RIGHT BECAUSE WHEN YOU'RE
HIRING SO MANY FOLKS AND YOU
CAN'T GET EVERYONE THE HOUSE
AND HOUSING EXPERTISE SO WE
DEVELOPED IN HOUSE TRAINING
PROGRAM THAT ALLOWED US TO TAKE
THESE NEW FOLKS. SO THE WHOLE
GOAL OF THIS NEVER RECEIVED
WHEN SEEM PLAN WAS REALLY TO
AND- DELIVER UPON SPECIFIC
COMMITMENTS TO OUR STAKEHOLDERS
THE FIRST OF THOSE BEING THAT
WE WANT TO MEET PUBLISHED.
THERE IS A PENDING AVAILABILITY
DATES WE HAVE ENOUGH AYE
CALENDAR THAT'S PUBLIC ON AND
PUBLISHED ON OUR WEBSITE I
THINK YOU HAVE A COPY IT OF IN
YOUR AGENDA SO WE WANT TO
ENSURE THAT WHEN WE SAY WE'RE
GOING TO RELEASE ENOUGH IN
JANUARY. WE ISSUE THAT NO FAT
IN JANUARY BECAUSE FOLKS ARE.
RELYING ON THE AVAILABILITY OF
THOSE PLANS WHEN THEY'RE
PUTTING TOGETHER THESE REALLY
COMPLICATED PROJECTS AND THE
SECOND WAS STANDARD AGREEMENT
WHETHER PLATES WE WENT TO HAVE
THOSE UP IN AVAILABLE AND AT
THE TIME OF A WARD SO THAT. THE
FOLKS THAT ARE GETTING THESE
FUNDS CAN LOOK AT THE STANDARD
AGREEMENTS. AND START TO REVIEW
THOSE WELL WE'RE HEARING THOSE
IN HOUSE WITH THE ULTIMATE GOAL
OF HAVING SCARED CREAM AND
ROUTE SO WHAT EASE WITHIN THE
DAY AWARD. SO THOSE WERE. DOES
GOALS WITHIN THE REGION HERE
PROCESS THESE THE
ORGANIZATIONAL RESTRUCTURING
AND TRADE IN THE IN THE FRONT
THE BILL PLEASE THE AWARD AND
JUST TO PRESS. HOW BECOME
QUICKER. MORE EFFICIENT AND IN
FACT SINCE THE LAUNCH OF OUR RE
SEQUENCING PLANNED THE
DEPARTMENT HAS ISSUED EIGHT
NOTICES A FUNNY AVAILABILITY.
ALL BY THE PROJECTED DATE
CENTER NOW IF I CALENDAR AND
SIX OF NOVAS THAT WERE RE
SEQUENCE DEAN BUT- THAT WERE
ORIGINALLY RE SEQUENCED THREE
OF THOSE PROGRAMS UP AND THAT
IS THE FUNNY AVAILABILITY HAS
BEEN RELEASED. WITH AT LEAST
THE CAL HOME PROGRAM IN
NOVEMBER. THE JOE STERN A FARM
WORKER GRANT PROGRAM THAT WAS
RELEASED IN DECEMBER AND THEN
I'M AT LOCAL HAPPY NO OCCASION
PROGRAM WHICH IS THE SEVENTY
SEVENTY CENT OF LOCAL IS. THERE
A TO THE BUILDING HOMES AND
POPS TAUGHT ACTIVITIES
SEVENTEEN THAT WAS IT IN
FEBRUARY THE REMAINING. THREE
NOW IS THAT WERE RE RE
SEQUENCED THOSE TRAPPED THE
ISSUE WITHIN THE- THAT'S- GOOD
FOR ALL. WILL HAVE. NO IF ISSUE
IN STATES THAT WERE PAUSED FOR
A THREE MONTH PERIOD. IT
ALLOWED US TO RE WORK IN RE
ENGINEER SOME OF OUR INTERNAL
PROCESS SEES. AND THE RESULT IS
THAT AWARDS ARE ACTUALLY GOING
TO BE MADE SOONER THAN THEY
WOULD HAVE BEEN. UNDER IF WE
HAD NOT PROCEEDED WITH ENOUGH
EVERY SEQUENCING PLANNED. FOR
EXAMPLE AND- ARE CAL HOME
PROGRAM THAT WAS ONE OF THE SIX
PROGRAMS THAT WAS RE SEQUENCED.
IT WAS ORIGINALLY PLANNED TO BE
RELEASED IN SEPTEMBER OF TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN. AM WITH
AWARDS ANTICIPATED A MARCH
TWENTY TWENTY. AM BUT EACH SEAT
WAS TYPICALLY RUNNING BETWEEN
FIFTY AND A HUNDRED DAYS
BEHIND. THE AWARD DATE THAT WE
HAD PUBLISHED INTERNET
CALENDAR. AND WE WOULD HAVE
MEANT IF WE ISSUED THAT IN
SEPTEMBER TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN
WITHOUT TAKE. AND WITHOUT THE
RE ENGINEER PROCESS SEES
INTERNALLY. AND THOSE AWARDS
WOULD HAVE BEEN MADE PROBABLY
AND LET AND EARLY JUNE- LATE
JUNE EARLY JULY OF TWENTY
TWENTY. WE RE SEQUENCE THAT NO
FAT. FOR NOVEMBER IT WAS
RELEASED NOVEMBER TWENTY
SEVENTH WITH AWARDS ANTICIPATED
IN MAY OF TWENTY TWENTY. WE'RE
ON TRACK TO. MAY TWENTY TWENTY
DEADLINE WHICH IS REALLY FORTY
FIVE DAYS EARLIER THAN IT WOULD
HAVE BEEN RELEASED HAD WE NOT
HAD THE OPPORTUNITY. TO GO IN
SEASON OFFICE AND FOCUS ON
STREAMLINING INTERNAL
PROCESSES. AND SO. HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY. YOU MAY HAVE BUT I
THINK IT HAS BEEN A AT A
POSITIVE DIRECTION FOR THE
APARTMENT AND IT'S ALLOWING US
TO. DEFINITELY MORE EFFICIENTLY
I'M AN EXPEDITION LEE DELIVER-
THESE CRITICAL RESOURCES. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THIS
IS A- OVERSIGHT ITEM WEREN'T NO
ACTION IS REQUIRED- BUT I JUST
WANT TO SAY THAT I REALLY
APPRECIATE YOUR- PRESENTATION
YOU'RE SPEAKING. MY LANGUAGE
STANDARDIZED RE ENGINEERED
STREAMLINED AND EXPEDITING- AND
I THINK IT HELPS SOME OF THE
ISSUES THAT I'VE HEARD FROM THE
DEVELOPMENT COMMUNITY- IN
REGARDS TO- APPLICATIONS THEY
HAVE EITHER PENDING OR THAT
THEY RECEIVED IN. THE FACT THAT
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT
STANDARDIZED AGREEMENTS MORE
RECENTLY AS YESTERDAY THAT WAS
ONE OF THE ISSUES THAT WERE IT
WAS RAISED WITH ME- SO I REALLY
APPRECIATE- ANY QUESTIONS. YES
SENATOR A LOT IS IN PROCESS AND
A LOT MORE THE- FOURTH COMING
THIS YEAR. IF COMMENTED ABOUT
HOW DIFFERENT LEGISLATIVE
PROPOSALS OF EXPEDITE. HAVE
EXACERBATED YOUR WORKLOAD. AB
COULD YOU HAVE DEVELOPED A
PROCESSOR WAY TO MORE REGULARLY
A PRICE THE COMMITTEE OF HOW
YOUR FROM PROCEEDING WITH SO WE
CAN BE BETTER ASSESSING AND NOT
HAVING THAT BIG BIG BUILD UP OR
A DELAY OF MONEY'S GOING OUT-
THAT'S A SO THAT'S IT'S BEEN AN
ONGOING PROBLEM AND I KNOW
YOU'RE WORKING ON IT BUT WHAT
I'M LOOKING AT IS NOT JUST
WAITING TILL NEXT YEAR TO GET
UPDATED AS YOU'RE DOING HERE
FOR US TODAY BUT RATHER
SOMEWHERE IN THE INTERIM THAT
WE GET MORE REGULAR REPORTS DO
YOU DO THAT- CAN YOU DO THAT.
WOULD YOU PUBLISH SOME
INFORMATION ON OUR WEBSITE IT'S
AN- NOTE M. AWARDS ARE MADE BUT
I THINK WE CAN DEFINITELY. AND
PUT SOMETHING TOGETHER AND
PROVIDE THAT INFORMATION TO YOU
JUST KIND OF. I'M WORKING WITH
YOU TO UNDERSTAND WHAT YOU'RE
INTERESTED IN AND HOW WE CAN
PROVIDE THAT DATA FOR I'D LIKE
TO WORK EARLY ON THAT MAYBE
SOME LITTLE LANGUAGE IN THE
BUDGET THEN. OKAY FORCE
REPORTING CONTROL LANGUAGE
THANK YOU. GOOD CENTER DROSS OF
YEAH. SINCE I'M IN THE PROCESS
STILL OF LEARNING. ON ALL THESE
DIFFERENT PROGRAMS AND THERE'S
MORE IN A RECESSION. WHAT
SENATE GE OF. WHAT DID YOU DO
IS IN THIS MAY BE DIFFICULT TO
BREAK DOWN IS- GOING TO ARE
HOMELESS. PROGRAMS IS THEIR WAY
OF. GETTING AT THAT A LITTLE
BIT I GUESS WHAT I'M GETTING
THAT'S NOT A TRICK QUESTION IS-
AS YOU GO THROUGH THESE MOMENTS
OF. YOU KNOW NOT HAVING THE
STAFF FILLING VACANCIES IS. HOW
DO YOU PRIORITIZE CD IS IT A
PRIORITY HOW DO YOU DEAL WITH
SO MANY PROGRAMS THAT ARE
TRYING TO DEAL WITH THE
DIFFERENT ASPECTS OF OUR
HOUSING CRISIS SO I WOULD SAY
WE ADDRESS HOMELESSNESS ON A
VARIETY OF DIFFERENT FRONTS WE
HAVE THE PROGRAMS WHICH ARE AND
WITHIN THE DIVISION OF
FINANCIAL ASSISTANCE SO THAT
INCLUDES ARE NO PLACE LIKE HOME
PROGRAM ARE VETERANS
HOMELESSNESS. AND HOUSING
PREVENTION PROGRAM WE ALSO
RECENTLY FINISHED UP THE
CALIFORNIA EMERGENCY SOLUTIONS
FOR HOUSING PROGRAM THAT WAS.
AND WHICH WE'VE NOW ALL
ALLOCATED AND SO. WE CONTINUE
TO ROLL THROUGH THOSE PROGRAMS
WERE ISSUING ANYONE KNOW FIRST
FOUR FULL FOR NO PLACE LIKE
HOME AND THE VETERANS HOUSING.
AND PROGRAM- MOST RECENTLY
RELEASED I THINK IN THE LAST
TWO TO THREE MONTHS WE'VE
APPLICATIONS IN THE HOUSE SO
THAT'S ON AN ANNUAL CALENDAR
EYES BASIS FOR ISSUING OFFICE
BUT SOCK IN HIS TEAM AND
HOUSING. AND POLICY DEVELOPMENT
DIVISION ALSO HAVE A ROLE IN
HOMELESSNESS SO IF YOU HAVE YOU
HAVE A NO FOR COUNTY FROM YOU
MAYBE TO ADD A LITTLE POINT TO
THAT SO. THE SECOND LINE ITEM
V. EIGHT EIGHT FIFTY THAT'S
SPECIFIC TO HOMELESS VETERANS
AND LOW INCOME VETERANS TO FOR
EXAMPLE YOU'LL FEEL A LOT OF
WILL NOT 100% ALWAYS A
SIGNIFICANT PORTION OF THAT
FUNDING. GOING TOWARD HOMELESS
VETERANS WE HAVE SOME SPECIFIC
PROGRAMS TARGET TO SPECIFIC
SEGMENTS OF THE HOMELESS
POPULATION THAT'S ONE OF THEM.
NO PLACE LIKE HOME WAS
MENTIONED THAT SPECIFIC OF
COURSE TO CHRONICALLY HOMELESS
FOLKS WHO ALSO EXPERIENCING
MENTAL ILLNESS- IF YOU GO DOWN
A LITTLE BIT LOWER FOR THROUGH
THE BOTTOM WE C. H. H. C. THAT
IS FEDERAL FUNDS WE GET FOR.
LOW INCOME HOUSEHOLDS ONE
NATURAL IT SERVICE CALL THE
FOLKS WHO ARE CURRENTLY WAS.
THE LEASE PROGRAM. BILL ALMOST.
ALL OF PROGRAMS YOU DO BETTER
IF YOU'RE- THE DEEP A LOWER IN
LEVEL OR SERVING HER FOLKS EVEN
IT'S NOT A REQUIREMENT. OF THAT
BRING SO EVEN OUR- PROGRAM THE
BIGGEST PROGRAM THE MULTI
FAMILY HOUSING PROGRAM THE
RECENT AWARDS WE ISSUED THERE
ARE QUITE A FEW PROJECTS ARE
FOR PERMITS SUPPORTER HOUSING.
EVEN THOUGH IT WAS A LOT OF IN
THE HOUSING PROGRAM. THEY WERE
SERVING HOMELESS SUCKS SO EVEN
THOUGH. THE MATH IS A LITTLE
ROUGH RIGHT WE HAVE SPECIFIC
PROGRAMS THAT. TOTALLY JUST GO
TO FROM WAS HOME WITH US BUT
EVEN WITHIN THE OTHER PROGRAMS.
WE OFTEN. THEY ALMOST ALWAYS
THESE DAYS YOU'RE GONNA SEE AT
LEAST A HANDFUL OF NOT HALF OF
THOSE AWARDS FEATURING. SOME
SEGMENT HOMELESS POPULATION
IT'S- MAYBE NOT A 100% OF THAT
PRODUCT HISTORY FOLKS OR
HOMELESS IT MIGHT BE. 30% OF
THOSE UNITS A TARGET. PEOPLE
HOMELESS THE OTHER. YOU KNOW
PERCENTAGES ARE AT PEOPLE AT
60% OF THE AREA MEDIAN INCOME
OR SOMETHING LIKE THAT THEY CAN
BE QUITE QUITE COMPLEX BUT WE
HAVE BUILT IN. WI SAFE FROM
POLICY PERSPECTIVE AN ADVANTAGE
TO DEVELOPERS IF THEY ARE
CHOOSING TO SERVE IN THEIR
APPLICATIONS EVEN FOR THE
PROGRAMS THAT ARE NOT
SPECIFICALLY TARGET. ASSIST IF
THEY'RE DOING SO. NOW WE CAN
GIVE YOU A LITTLE BIT MORE
DETAIL BUT IT IT'S A ON A
PROJECT UBER PROJECT LEVEL. IT
CAN BE COMPLICATED RIGHT
BECAUSE EVERY PROJECT CAN BE.
EVEN WITH EVERYTHING. THANK YOU
I JUST WANT GOING BACK TO THE
STAFFING- IF. YOU WENT THROUGH
THE RECRUITMENT- HIGHER RAIN
AND THE START DATE. COULD YOU
JUST QUICKLY SAME THING ABOUT
THE RETENTION. SINCE THE
PROCESS. IS YOU'RE TRYING TO
SPEED UP THE PROCESS WHICH I
REALLY APPRECIATE. BUT
SOMETIMES THAT DOESN'T
NECESSARILY MEAN YOU KEEP
EVERYBODY. ACHY AND RETENTION
IS KEY BECAUSE IT IMPACTS THE
VACANCY RATE AS WE DISCUSSED
EARLIER. SO SOME THINGS ARE
DOING IS WE DO HAVE A NEW
EMPLOYEE- A NEW EMPLOYEE
ORIENTATION PROGRAM THAT. EVERY
SINGLE EMPLOYEE THAT'S NEW TO
HOUSING COMMITTEE OF ELEMENT
DOES IT DOES HAVE TO TEN. AND
ACTUALLY I'VE BEEN AROUND STATE
SERVICE FOR NINETEEN YEARS AS
BY THE BEST PROGRAM I'VE EVER
SEEN AS FAR AS TRYING TO KEEP.
FOLKS ON BOARDED- WE HAD AN
UNUSUALLY LARGE AMOUNT OF FOLKS
THAT RETIRED LAST YEAR- I WOULD
SAY ONE THIRD OVER DEPARTMENT
ARE FOLKS THAT HAVE BEEN THERE
FOR FIFTEEN OR TWENTY YEARS OR
MORE- AND THEN YOU GOT LIKE TWO
THIRDS. RELATIVELY BRAND NEW
AND SO I ANTICIPATE THE VACANCY
RATE PART OF HOW IT'S FOLKS
LEAD. TO DRAMATIC. NOW TWENTY
YEARS OR SO- PROBABLY TO BE
THERE FOR A FEW FOR A LITTLE
BIT LONGER AND WE DEFICIT ONE
OR TEN ON THE FOLKS THAT WE
JUST BROUGHT ON BOARD WHICH IS
ABOUT. ALMOST TWO THIRDS OF OUR
WHOLE DEPARTMENT SO. ANTICIPATE
IT WILL GO DOWN BUT I THINK
PART OF IT IS OUR NEW EMPLOYEE
ORIENTATION. TO GET FOLKS REAL
COMFORTABLE QUICKLY. ON WHAT WE
DO- AND I THINK JUST EXCITEMENT
IT'S GENERATED NOW WITH ALL THE
NEW PROGRAMS THAT WE HOUSE- BUT
THE KEY IS KEEP FIRING AND THEN
TRY TO KEEP THE FOLKS THAT WE
HAVE AND MAKE SURE THAT THEY'RE
TRAINED. AND HAVE THE TOOLS TO
BE SUCCESSFUL AND I THINK
THAT'S WHAT OUR GOAL TO KEEP
FOLKS FROM LEAVING. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH- LET ME JUST SAY THAT
THE- SHE WHAT YOU'VE DONE AND
IN TERMS OF MAKING THE CHANGES
TO HIRE THAT'S REALLY IMPORTANT
AND I THINK YOU'VE YOU'VE GIVEN
US A GOOD. EXPLANATION I AGREE
WITH A MY COLLEAGUE- IN REGARDS
TO PHYLLIS FIGURE OUT A WAY TO
KIND OF KEEP US ABREAST OF
WHAT'S GOING ON- THAT THE NO
FIVE- SLIDING WAS OF CONCERN
BECAUSE I'D HAVE CONVERSATIONS
WITH STAFF ABOUT WHEN IS THE
FORMER HOUSING GREG GOING TO GO
OUT AND I WAS TOLD TO DATE AND
THEN IT WOULD SLIP THREE
MONTHS. AND WHEN I ASKED IS
THERE A WAY FOR YOU LET ME KNOW
BUT- HAVE TOLD PEOPLE. IT'S
COMING OUT IN APRIL AND IT'S
NOW JULY AND IT IT HASN'T
MOVED- I WAS TOLD NO WE DON'T
HAVE THE RESOURCES TO BE
ADVISING. YOU KNOW MEMBERS OF
THE LEGISLATURE WHICH I CAN
UNDERSTAND BUT THERE'S GOT TO
BE A SYSTEM. WHERE IF YOU'RE IF
WE'RE TOLD SOMETHING AND WE'VE
COMMUNICATED IT. TOO THE-
PEOPLE WHO ARE WILLING AND
READY TO BUILD HOUSING RIGHT-
WE NEED TO. HAVE A WAY OF BEING
ABLE TO BE SURE THAT- EITHER
THAT WE GET A CALL TO SAY HEY
YOU KNOW WHAT IT'S SLIPPING AND
IT'S NOT GONNA HAPPEN OR WE CAN
LOOK AT THAT. AT THE- AT THE
END NOTICE AND KNOW THAT IT'S
ACTUALLY GOING TO GO OUT. THE
WAY IT IS SO I APPRECIATE. AT
SOME BOTTOM THAT IN AND IT
DOESN'T HAVE TO BE. COMPLICATED
IT'S JUST I THINK WE NEED TO
KNOW WERE OUT THERE PUSHING
DEVELOPERS. AND THIS IS THIS IS
REALLY IMPORTANT AND- THE
ABILITY TO STANDARDIZING
GRIEVANCES VERY IMPORTANT.
BECAUSE THE DEVELOPERS ARE
SPENDING A LOT OF MONEY ON
ATTORNEYS TO REVIEW AND WHILE I
LIKE THAT BECAUSE I'M AN
ATTORNEY I ALSO UNDERSTAND THAT
THAT MAKES IT HARDER FOR THE
UNITS TO BE AFFORDABLE AND SO
THE MORE THAT WE CAN-
STREAMLINE THAT PROCESS BECAUSE
THEY MAY BE ELIGIBLE FOR MORE
THAN ONE. GRANT AND THE MORE
THAT WE CAN DO STREAMLINING THE
BETTER IT IS SO. VERY GOOD OKAY
WELL THIS IS- AND NO ACTION
REQUIRED THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR BEING HERE TODAY
APPRECIATE- YOUR PRESENTATION.
AND IT IT LOOKS LIKE IT'S GOING
IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION NOW WE
JUST NEED TO GET A DIRECTOR I'M
ANXIOUS TO GET IT DIRECTOR SO.
FAR THANK YOU. A WILL MOVE ON
TO ISSUE NUMBER TEN WHICH IS
THE WORK WORKLOAD RESOURCES YES
ISSUE NUMBER TEN EIGHT CD
REQUESTED GENERAL FUND
AUGMENTATION OF FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS FOR TWENTY TWO
POSITIONS IN FISCAL YEAR TWENTY
TWENTY ONE. FOUR MILLION
DOLLARS FOR TWENTY TWO
POSITIONS AND FISCAL YEAR
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO. FOUR
MILLION FOR SEVENTEEN POSITIONS
OF FISCAL YEAR. TWENTY TWO
TWENTY THREE. AND FINALLY FOR
MILLION FOR SIXTEEN POSITIONS
OF FISCAL YEAR TWENTY THREE
TWENTY FOUR. AN ON GOING TO
ADDRESS THE WORKLOAD ASSOCIATED
WITH ENFORCEMENT OF HOUSING
LAWS. PASSED DURING THE TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN LEGISLATIVE
SESSION AB ANSWERING QUESTIONS.
OKAY NO COMMENT FROM ANYBODY
ELSE AND QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE. QUESTION I KNOW
QUESTIONS ON THIS ONE THIS WILL
REMAIN OPEN AND WE'LL GET BACK
TO ANOTHER TIME ISSUE NUMBER
ELEVEN TRANSIT ORIENTED
DEVELOPMENT PROGRAM ALIGNMENT
ISSUE ELEVEN EIGHTY CD
REQUESTED APPROPRIATION
INCREASE OF FIFTY THREE MILLION
DOLLARS. FOR FISCAL YEAR. AND
THIRTY SEVEN MILLION DOLLARS IN
FISCAL YEAR TWENTY ONE TWENTY
TWO AND LOCAL SYSTEMS FOR THE
TRANSIT ORIENTED DEVELOPMENT
PROGRAM HAPPY TO ANSWER
QUESTIONS. RE GOOD QUESTIONS OF
THE COMMITTEE. SEEING NO
QUESTION. I DON'T HAVE ANY
EITHER- THIS IS THE
RECOMMENDATION IS TO APPROVE IS
BUDGETED OF THIS I UNDERSTAND
IS TO MOVE MONEY OUT. HE A
NUMBER OF YEARS IS THAT CORRECT
SO THAT WE CAN GET IT OUT AS
QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE THAT MAKES
ME HAPPY. YEAH OKAY VERY GOOD
IS THERE A MOTION BY THIS SITE
IS A- AN ITEM THAT WE'RE GONNA
VOTE ON TODAY IS OR ANYBODY
FROM THE PUBLIC THAT WOULD LIKE
TO MAKE A PUBLIC COMMENT AT
THIS TIME. LIKE TO INVITE YOU
TO COME TO THE MIKE. SEEING NO
MOVEMENT SING THEM NO ONE I'LL
ENTERTAIN A MOTION. THEM THEM
THERE IS A MOTION TO APPROVE
THIS PLEASE CALDERON CABALLERO
HI NIELSEN DRAWS A- VERY GOOD.
MOVE ON TO ITEM NUMBER TWELVE
WHICH IS THE FEDERAL COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT BLOCK GRANT
DISASTER RECOVERY GRANT
ADJUSTMENT. SO HGV REQUEST A
FEDERAL TRUST FUND AUGMENTATION
OF EIGHTY EIGHT MILLION DOLLARS
IN FISCAL YEAR TWENTY TWENTY
ONE. HUNDRED SIXTY NINE
THOUSAND DOLLARS ON GOING FOR
ONE POSITION TO OVERSEE THE
DISTRIBUTION OF THE TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT BLOCK GRANT
DISASTER RELIEF FUNDS FOR
DISASTER PREPAREDNESS AND
MITIGATION THE- ANSWER
QUESTIONS RE GOOD ANY QUESTIONS
OF. JUST SENATOR DRAWS A
DOCUMENTARY AND JUST TO CLARIFY
SO THIS IS FEDERAL FUNDING
THAT'S CORRECT FEDERAL FUNDING
THAT WERE JUST AGREEING TO TAKE
US. OKAY NOT A BAD DEAL SO MOVE.
WELL THERE IS A MOTION IN IT
THIS IS AN ITEM THAT WE WILL BE
VOTING ON SO IS THERE ANY
PUBLIC COMMENT ON THIS SIDE OF
ANYBODY OPPOSED TO TAKING.
MONEY. SO THE MAN THAT HERE-
FOR MY HUSBAND LIKE AFFAIRS
HERE ON BEHALF OF HABITAT FOR
HUMANITY AND WE JUST WANTED TO
SAY THANK YOU FOR THE SUPPORT.
THESE ARE FUNDS THAT HABITAT
HAS UTILIZED IN PLACES LIKE
BUTTE COUNTY PARTICULARLY. SO
WE APPRECIATE EVERYTHING THAT'S
BEING DONE TO IMPLEMENT THIS
AND TO SPEED UP THE PROCESS I
THINK IT'S GREAT. THANK YOU SO
MUCH. THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE
TODAY. ANYONE ELSE. TING NO
FURTHER PUBLIC COMMENT THERE IS
A MOTION UP THE ROLE PLEASE.
CABALLERO I NIELSEN RAZA.
MOTION PASSES THANK YOU MOVING
ON TO ISSUE NUMBER THIRTEEN THE
HOUSING DEVELOPMENT TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE. H. CD REQUESTED A
LOCAL ASSISTANCE GENERAL FUND
AUGMENTATION OF TEN MILLION
DOLLARS FOR FISCAL YEAR TWENTY
TWENTY ONE TWENTY ONE TWENTY
TWO AND TWENTY TO TWENTY THREE
PROVIDE TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE TO
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO HELP THEM
DEVELOP NEW HOUSING PROJECTS TO
MEET STATE HOUSING GOALS. WE
HAVE AN ANSWER THE QUESTION
THREE GOOD IS THERE ANY
QUESTIONS OF THE COMMITTEE ARE
ALEJO. SENATOR TENER DRIES OFF.
YEAH I'M JUST TRYING TO GET
CLEAR HERE WHAT THE PURPOSE OF
THIS FUNDING IS. AN I SEE SORT
OF A DUPLICATE HERE. AND WE'RE
TRYING TO GET THIS MONEY OUT TO
BUILD. FOR HOUSING RIGHT IN FOR.
HOUSING DEVELOPMENT TO HAVE A
QUICK REVIEW THAT I HAVE THAT
WHAT I SEE FROM THIS IS. A
TOTAL OF THIRTY MILLION DOLLARS
TEN MILLION THREE YEAR RIGHT
CORRECT THAT'S GOING TO GO
TOWARDS. MORE LIKE PLANNING. TO
THIS FIRST TWO HUNDRED FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS IN GRANTS TO
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO PLAN. FOUR
OF HOUSING DEVELOPMENT OF. IT
SEEMS LIKE A REAL DUPLICATE
HERE OF A LOT OF MONEY AND I
DON'T UNDERSTAND WHY WE WOULD
HAVE TO DO THAT IF WE'VE
ALREADY ALLOCATED TO A FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS FOR PLANNING
AND ANOTHER THIRTY MILLION
DOLLARS. OR PLANNING WHAT THIS
SOMETHING LET ME ADDRESS THAT
ARE THE EXACT ON SAID THE
PROJECT OVER HOUSING POLICY THE
CITY OF THIS IS A PROPOSAL FROM
THE GOVERNOR JANUARY BUDGET SO-
THAT'S WHY YOU'RE SEEING IT
HERE. AND YOU ARE CORRECT WE'VE
ACTUALLY DONE A PRETTY DECENT
INFUSION OF PLANNING RESOURCES
TO LOCAL GOVERNMENTS STARTING
WITH SENATE BILL TWO- WHICH
WERE NEARLY ALMOST AWARDED AND
THEN FROM LAST YEAR'S BUDGET
ANOTHER TWO HUNDRED FIFTY
MILLION OUT DIRECTLY TO CITIES
AND COUNTIES- AND THEN DIRECTLY
TO REGION'S. ON THOSE NUMBERS
ARE AVAILABLE ON THE STREET
WHAT WE HAVE FOUND IS THROUGH
THE TACKLE SYSTEMS PROVIDED FOR
THOSE PROGRAMS. WE HAVE REALLY
BEEN ABLE TO HELP COMMUNITIES
AND URGE THEM OF COURSE
ESPECIALLY STARTING WITH THE
SENATE BILL TWO FUNDS TO ENGAGE
IN PLAIN PRACTICES THAT MAKE
THEM MORE PRO HOUSING. RIGHT
THE TAKE AWAY BARRIERS THAT
MAKE ME A LITTLE GETTING DOWN
TO THE NITTY GRITTY OF PASSING
ORDINANCES- THAT CAN. MAKE IT
EASIER BE MORE FERTILE GROUND
TO RECEIVE HOUSING DEVELOPMENT.
AND SO THE SENATE BILL TWO
FUNDS WERE. HEAVILY TARGETED
TOWARDS ACCELERATING HOUSING
PRODUCTION AND SO ARTICLE
SYSTEMS RESOURCES THAT WE WERE
ABLE PROVIDE THEIR ALLOWED US
TO BE OUT IN COMMUNITIES WITH A
C. STAFF WITH A PR STAFF WITH
ACTUAL CONSOLES WITH HIGHER TO
GET THEM READY TO UNDERSTAND
HOW TO USE THOSE FUNDS AND
APPLY FOR THEM WE GOT VERY GOOD
RESULTS IN TERMS OF. NEARLY
EVERY CITY APPLYING FOR THOSE
FOR. WE ARE NOW GOING TO HAVE
ON THE HEELS THIS OTHER PLANT
THIS OTHER PLANNING RESOURCES
WHICH IN LAST YEAR'S BUDGET
WERE DESIGNED TO GET THEM READY
FOR THE SIX THE PLANNING CYCLE.
ESSENTIALLY HOW THESE OWN FOR
THEIR HOUSING NEEDS AND THEIR
HOUSING ELEMENT FOLLOWING THE
NUMBERS THEY GET. FROM US AND
THEN DOWN TO THE REGIONS IN THE
REGIONAL HOUSING NEEDS
ALLOCATION. AND SO THOSE
RESOURCES ARE REALLY REALLY DID
DIRECTED TOWARDS THAT PLANNING
ACTIVITY. AND WE HAVE NOTICED
IS WE WOULD LIKE THE
CONTINUITY. OF BEING ABLE TO
ASSIST THEM IN THOSE PROCESS
THESE WE GET QUITE A FEW
QUESTIONS- ON TOP OF THEM YOU.
NOT HOT HARKING BACK TO THE
PREVIOUS ITEM BUT THE NUMBER OF
PIECES LEGISLATION WE PASSED
THE LAST SEVERAL YEARS THAT
AFFECT THAT HOUSING ON THE
PLANNING PROCESS ARE
SIGNIFICANT. AND WHILE WE ARE
ABLE ISSUE QUITE A BIT OF
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE BY WAY OF
MEMORANDUMS AND THOSE SORTS OF
THINGS- REGULAR CAUGHT
CONTINUED- INTERACTION WITH A
LOOK GOVERNMENT HOW THEY
ACTUALLY APPLY THOSE LAWS AND
MAKE THEIR POLICIES GONNA MORE.
HOUSING DO THE ACTUAL NITTY
GRITTY ON THE GROUNDWORK OF HOW
TO GET THERE. IS QUITE
IMPORTANT- IT'S ONE THING TO
PUT THE WORDS ON A PAGE IN THE
CIRCUS ON THIS WAY IT'S ANOTHER
TO HELP THEM THROUGH THAT. AND
ONE WAY THESE COULD BE.
CONTINUE THOSE THOSE PRACTICES
THAT WE HAD FOR THE
PROGRAMMATIC USES OVER THE LAST
COUPLE YEARS RIGHT SO. IT COULD
BE AND I WOULD PROBABLY
RECOMMEND THIS IF WE SAW THESE
FUNDS. LACE IS US RETAINING.
CANCELED WE CAN SEND ON DEMAND.
TO ANY ANY JURISDICTION THAT
DEMANDS THAT INTEREST ME THE
JURISDICTIONS WILL DEMAND IT.
TO HELP THEM THROUGH THIS
PROCESS TO MEET THEM WHERE
THEY'RE AT. LARGE JURISDICTIONS
MAY NOT NEED HELP IN DEVELOPING
AN ORDINANCE ARE GETTING IT
PASSED THEY MAY HAVE A MORE
TECH LEASE BUT SMALLER
JURISDICTIONS. MAY ACTUALLY
NEED HELP WITH SAMPLE
ORDINANCES AND THOSE SORTS OF
THINGS SO WE HAVE FOUND THROUGH
THE- TECH ASSISTANCE WE WERE
ABLE TO PROVIDE. THE SENATE
BILL TO PROCESS A LOT OF
REALLY. GOOD THINGS HAPPENING.
AT THE LOCAL LEVEL. A LOT OF
SELF REPORTED INTO THE ACTIONS
THEY'RE GOING TO TAKE WITH
THESE PLANNING DOLLARS.
ACCELERATING HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF YEARS OF HOUSING
PRETENTIOUS TO DO ENVIRONMENTAL
REVIEW AS THEY DO. YOU KNOW
EXPEDITED PERMITTING PROCESS
TIMES AND WE DON'T WANT TO SEE
THAT TO BE A ONE. ONE ONE STOP
WANT A ONE TIME THING RIGHT.
THE NEED IS REALLY GREAT FOR
OUR OUR ENGAGEMENT WITH LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS TO HELP THEM DO
WHATEVER THEY CAN TO GET TO
APPROVE HOUSING TO MAKE IT SO
THEY ARE FERTILE GROUND TO HAVE
DEVELOPERS INTERESTED IN IN
BUILDING THERE AND- AND I THINK
THAT'S THAT'S THE IDEA BEHIND
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL TO HAVE
A CONTINUED KIND OF DROP OF
TACKLE SYSTEMS OF COST AS
OPPOSED TO JUST FOCUS ON A
SPECIFIC PROGRAM RIGHT SO WE
BROKE WE DO TEXAS FOR THE
PROGRAM THEN YOU DON'T THAT
PROGRAM IT KIND OF GOES WE
WOULD LIKE THERE TO BE THAT
ONGOING EXPERTISE BUILT THE
LOCAL LEVEL BECAUSE QUITE.
OFTEN IF EVEN IF THEY RECEIVE A
PLANNING GRANT THEY MAY BE
SPEAKING AT THE TURN AROUND
HIGHER CONSULTANT TO DO WE WORK
PRODUCT LIKE THEY'RE HOUSING
ELEMENT BUT THEY'RE NOT
RETAINING THAT EXPERTISE ALWAYS
AT THE LOCAL LEVEL FOR OUR
SMALLER COMMUNITIES WHO DON'T
HAVE THE ON GOING LOOK
RESOURCES TO RETAIN A LOT OF
PLANNING STAFF SO IF WE'RE ABLE
TO SECURE- KIND OF ON DEMAND
ASSISTANCE IN A CIRCUIT RIDER
PLANER ASSISTANCE IF YOU WILL
TO BE ABLE TO HELP THEM WHEN
THE NEEDS ARISE- I WE EXPECT
WILL BE- ANY. THE LOCAL LEVEL
AND HOPEFUL EXPEDITED. APPROVAL
OF HOUSING WHEN IT WHEN IT
COMES ACROSS THEIR CITY COUNCIL
OR BOARD OF SUPERVISORS.
AGENDAS IT STILL SOUNDS VERY
DUPLICATIVE I MEAN THE QUESTION
OF. AGAIN IT WAS A VERY
EXPLICIT AMOUNTS OF MONEY SET
ASIDE FOR LOCAL GOVERNMENTS AND
IN PARTICULAR SMALLER OR THOSE
WHO DIDN'T HAVE RESOURCES-
PLANNING. SURE THAT'S THE FOR
THEIR PLANNING ACTIVITIES THIS
IS FOR THE TACKLE THIS IS
HELPING UTILIZED THAT WOULD BE
THE BEST WAY TO EXPLAIN IT BUT
HAPPY TO. HAVE ELABORATE BY AYE
AYE I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT I'M-
JUDY ON WHAT YOU SAID BUT I
WOULD LIKE THIS IS A HOLD OPEN
AND SO IN TERMS OF WHERE I'D
LIKE TO SEE THIS GO IS THAT- A
LOT OF THE TIMES. SO WHAT WHAT
WHAT HAPPENED IN THE DOWNTURN
IN THE ECONOMY IS IT THE- STAFF
OF THE SMALL COMMUNITIES
DISAPPEARED- AND EVEN IF THEY
HAD THEM THEY'RE THEY'RE GONE-
IN- THE SALINAS VALLEY SALINAS
ALWAYS HAD A PRETTY ROBUST
PLANNING STAFF AND THEY USED
TO. LOAN THEM PART TIME TO
HELP. COMMUNITIES WHEN THEY HAD
A DEVELOPMENT PROJECT- WHEN
THEY NEEDED YOU THE HOUSING
ELEMENT CELLS KINDS OF THINGS
AND- SO WE WERE WE SHARED A LOT
OF RESOURCES. THAT ALL
DISAPPEAR DURING THE DOWNTURN
IN THE ECONOMY AND EVERYBODY
WAS DOWN TO THE NOBODY'S IN
TERMS OF THAT PLANNERS. BUT BUT-
BUT HAVING SAID THAT MY BIGGEST
CONCERN IS JUST TO MAKE IT A
GRANT AND YOU CAN GO OUT AND
HIRE WHOEVER YOU WANT. BECAUSE
NOT ALL PLANNERS AND
CONSULTANTS ARE CREATED EQUAL
AND I LIKE THE IDEA OF HAVING.
BOB A CORE GROUP OR EIGHT
ORGANIZATION THAT'S GOT THE
HISTORY OF HELPING COMMUNITIES.
AND THEN SOME PERFORMANCE.
MEASUREMENTS IN IN PARTICULAR
THAT- OR BEST PRACTICES AND
USING NEW URBANIST PRINCIPLES-
IT WHEN THEY'RE DOING THE
REZONING THAT THE INCREASE
DENSITY INCREASED FOR AREA
RATIOS THAT THEY REDUCE
PARKING- THAT THEY HAVE AN EXIT
EXPEDITED PERMIT. PROCESS AND
MAYBE EVEN THAT THEY- AT THE
DATA SAMPLE STATE APPROVED
EIGHTY YOU- PROPOSAL. IF YOU
KNOW THE HARD THING ABOUT.
DOING AN ACCESSORY DWELLING
UNIT IS IT IS THAT YOU'VE GOT%
IT HAVE AN ARCHITECT THE COMES
IN MAKES IT DRYING AND THEN
THIS THE LOCAL STAFF HAS TO
LOOK AT IT AND THEN. OTHER
THAN. DOES THIS FIT IN MY YARD
AND DOES IT MEET THE SET BACKS
IF WE HAD A WHOLE SLEW OF
EIGHTY YOU. UP STATE APPROVED
PLANS THAT ARE OFF THE SHELF.
THEN EFECT COMMUNITY USES
THEM. THEN IT EXPEDITES. THE
PLANNING PROCESS AND- MAKES IT
A LOT EASIER FOR COMMUNITIES-
TO BE ABLE TO PUT THE MEN
BECAUSE THEY THEY'RE THEY'VE
ALREADY PASSED THAT SO I'M I'M
JUST LOOKING. AYE AYE. WITH THE
ONE THING I DON'T THINK WE'VE
DONE VERY WELL AS COME UP WITH
THAT WHOLE LIST OF. OF WAYS TO
EXPEDITE THAT ARE. THERE ARE.
THAT HAVE BEEN IDENTIFIED BY ME
IT USED TO BE NEW NEW URBANIST
IS NOW OLD BECAUSE WE'VE WAITED
A LONG TIME AGO NOW MOLD- BUT
BUT THERE ARE ALL KINDS OF
THINGS THAT WE COULD WE COULD
SAY THIS HAS TO BE PART OF YOUR
PLAN HERE'S THE CONSULTANT LIST
BUT HERE'S THE BUTTE YOU HAVE
TO AGREE THAT THESE ARE-
INCLUSIONARY HOUSING OR
ORDINANCES AT DENSITY BONUSES
BEYOND WHAT THE STATE- REQUIRES
THOSE KINDS OF THINGS TO MAKE
IT- SO THAT IF YOU'RE GONNA GET
THIS TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE YOU
GOT AGREE THAT YOU'RE GONNA AT
LEAST CONSIDER OFFER THIS MENU.
YEAH IT IN YOU KNOW WHAT WE DID
NOT SUCH A THE THIRTY WITH FOR
EXAMPLE WITH THE STARTING THIS
SB TO PLAYING GRANTS- TO SAY
YOU MUST WE HAD SIX POLICY
PRIORITY AREAS SOME OF WHICH
YOU MENTIONED EIGHTY YOU
POLICIES X. THEY REMAIN TIMES
OF MORE ZONING PERMITTED BY
RIGHT EXCEPT AROUND AND WE SAW
THAT 92% OF THE ACTIVITIES
PROPOSED BY THE CITY SO FAR SB
TO HAVE HAVE HAVE STUCK IN
THOSE. SO WE HAVE TRIED UP
LATER THOSE IN WE DID AGAIN
WITH KIND OF TALK ABOUT WHAT
PER HOUSING PRINCIPLES ARE IN
THE BUDGET LAST YEAR SO WE'RE
TRYING TO CONTINUALLY BEAT THAT
DRUM SO THE DO STEER THE
RESOURCES IN THE RIGHT WAY AND
SO I THINK THAT'S THE
BACKGROUND BEHIND THIS PROPOSAL
IS TO CONTINUE THAT COULD
WORKING MAKE FOR DOESN'T. ON
THE WEATHER ON THE VINE KNOWN
ONE. BUT CERTAIN APPRECIATE AND
YOUR COMMENTS AND HAPPY OR WITH
YOU IS THE FAIR TO SAY THIS IS
SO THAT. THE HOUSING ELEMENTS
AND THAT THE GENERAL PLANS ARE.
IN CONFORMITY WITH STATE LAW I
MEAN IS THAT RIGHT IS GOING TO
BE A HUGE PART OF THIS YES-
THERE'S A LIVE A LOT OF. NEW
REQUIREMENT THAT THESE HAVE TO
DO. MUCH HARD NUMBERS AS YOU
I'M SURE YOU'RE AWARE OF. AND
HOW YOU GET IT THAT ACTUALLY
FROM HIS OWN PERSPECTIVE. GIVEN
SOMEONE YOU LAWS IS GOING TO
REQUIRE MANY OF THE SITES EVEN
BE BY RIGHT. ALL SEASON ALL THE
THINGS YOU MENTIONED SO- WE
ALREADY OF COURSE ARE GETTING
QUITE A FEW QUESTIONS AND WE'RE
ABLE TO. HANDLES BEST WE CAN
BUT CERTAINLY WOULD LIKE TO BE
OUT THERE IN THE COMMUNITIES IN
WHICH WE CAN. I GUESS I'M JUST.
THANK YOU MENTOR- I GUESS I'M
JUST- CAN GET CONFUSED BETWEEN.
YOU KNOW. THE ADDITIONAL
STAFFING. RIGHT TO IMPLEMENT
THE- NEW LEGISLATION. THEN
THERE'S- THEN THERE'S-
PLANNING. WHERE WHERE DOES THIS
THIRTY MILLION DOLLARS. WE
INTEND FOR THAT TO GO- AND- YOU
KNOW HOW DOES IT FIT INTO. THE
YOU KNOW THE REQUEST FOR
ADDITIONAL STAFFING THAT YOU
HAVE TO FILL ANYWAY SO I DID SO
NO IT OBVIOUSLY THERE'S NO
EXPLANATION FOR WHAT THIS
THIRTY MILLION DOLLARS WITH. IT
WOULD BE A MORE BE USED HAS
BEEN EXPLAINED I THINK YOU
WOULD BE MORE IN LINE IT IS SO
THE DIGITAL POSITIONS HAVE TO
DO WITH OUR REVIEW AND ARE
NEEDING TO PROVIDE YOU KNOW. WE
HAVE WE'RE GONNA WE'RE GONNA DO
NUMBER TACKLE SYSTEMS NO MATTER
IF WE HAVE THIS FUNDING OR NOT
BUT AND WE HAVE A NUMBER OF NEW
OBLIGATIONS WELL AS IT COMES
REVIEW. TO POSTING TO WORK WITH
LOWGOVERNMENTS TO FULFILL
THEIR OBLIGATIONS THAT'S WHERE
THE NEW STAFF INCOMES IN OUR
DIVISION THIS AS MUCH MORE
SOMETHING WE PRIDE CONTRACT OUT
FOR ASSIST LIKE WE HAVE WITH
PREVIOUS PROGRAMS SO THAT WE
CAN SEND PEOPLE ACTUALLY A
FIELD WITH OUR STAFF
OCCASIONALLY BUT OFF A POINT OF
CONTACT WITH- CONTROLS BECAUSE
WE ALSO ACTUALLY I FOUND A AYE.
APPRECIATE THAT MEASURE BECAUSE
IT ALLOWS US TAX HAVE BETTER
PERFORMANCE METRICS WHEN WE ARE
ABLE TO WORK DIRECTLY WITH A
CONSULTANT PROVIDER THAT HAS
THAT EXPERTISE TO DEMAND FROM
THEM. PLEASE JUST WORK ON THESE
DELIVERABLES WITH WITH WITH
CITY EXCERPT COUNTY X. IT'S A
THAT WOULD BE THE WAY I WOULD
RECOMMEND WE PROBABLY DO IT I
THINK WE'VE SEEN TREMENDOUS
SUCCESS AND THAT THE POLLING
MODEL AS OPPOSED TO HIRING MORE
STAFF OURSELVES- BECAUSE- WE
GET A LOT MORE BANG FOR BUCK
THAT WAY WE'RE ABLE TO MEET
FOLKS WHERE THEY'RE AT. MORE
BECAUSE WE HAVE A MENU OF KIND
OF EXPERTS IN THE FIELD THAT
HAVE PLANNING BACKGROUNDS- WITH
A VARIETY FOR COMMUNITIES
NEEDS. EXACTLY IT'S STILL
DEEPLY. WERE HOLDING IT OPEN SO
IN ANY CASE WE'LL SEE THIS
AGAIN WE'LL HAVE ANOTHER
OPPORTUNITY TO TALK ABOUT IT
SOME MORE ISSUE NUMBER FOURTEEN
WHICH IS THE EMPLOYEE HOUSING
FIELD INSPECTION. ACT REQUEST
THREE HUNDRED AND FIFTY SIX
THOUSAND DOLLARS IN FISCAL YEAR
TWENTY TWENTY ONE AND THREE
HUNDRED AND NINETEEN THOUSAND
GOING. IN REIMBURSEMENT
AUTHORITY TO FIND TO DISTRICT
REPRESENTATIVE. TO ADDRESS
INCREASING INSPECTION WORKLOAD
FOR ALL EMPLOYEE HOUSING
FACILITIES. THE ANSWER
QUESTIONS WRITTEN. ANY
QUESTIONS. I'M I THINK I'M
GONNA HOLD THIS OPEN WE HAVE-
WE'RE SHORT IT'S COMMITTEE
MEMBER AND OUT OF RESPECT FOR
MY COLLEAGUE I'D LIKE TO THIS
OPEN UP I DON'T THINK THERE
WERE ANY ISSUES OR CONCERNS ON
IT SO EXPECTED TO MUCH MOVED.
WHEN WE COME BACK. ISSUE NUMBER
FIFTEEN WHICH IS THE LONG TERM
MONITORING AND COMPLIANCE
WORKLOAD. HM THE REQUESTED
INCREASED A ONE POINT FIVE
MILLION TO THE HOUSING REAL
VISITATION LOAN FUN AND FOUR
HUNDRED THIRTY ONE THOUSAND IN
REIMBURSEMENT AUTHORITY IF IN
FISCAL YEAR TWENTY TWENTY ONE
AND EIGHT POSITIONS. AND TWO
MILLION IN THE HOUSING REAL BIT
TATIAN LOAN FUND AND FOUR
HUNDRED SIXTEEN THOUSAND RAMBUS
ENOUGH ALREADY ON GOING FOR
ELEVEN POSITIONS TO PROVIDE
LONG TERM MONITORING AND
COMPLIANCE RESOLUTION. FOR
AFFORDABLE HOUSING PROJECTS
I'LL BE HAPPY TO ANSWER
QUESTIONS. NOTHING HELLO ANY
QUESTIONS FROM. I DON'T BELIEVE
WE HAVE ANY QUESTIONS THIS IS-
TO THEIR RECOMMENDATION IS TO
HOLD IT OPEN AND SO WE'LL DO
THAT THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY
MUCH AND THEN FINALLY- ISSUE
NUMBER SIXTEEN THE MULTI FAMILY
HOUSING PROGRAM CLEAN UP LAST
QUEST AGD REQUEST TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE TO CLEAN UP THE
HOUSING REAL BILL TATIAN LOAN
FUN AUTHORIZING EXPENDITURES OF
LOAN REPAYMENTS FROM LEGACY
PROGRAMS TO NEW LOANS. AND THE
MULTI FAMILY HOUSING PROGRAM TO
MAXIMIZE RESOURCES AVAILABLE
FOR MULTI FAMILY HOUSING
PRODUCTION FROM HAVE BEEN
ANSWERED QUESTIONS. ANY
QUESTIONS ON THIS ONE. I DON'T
BELIEVE SO I THINK THIS IS A
THIS IS ALSO A HOLD HOLD OPEN-
YOU KNOW WHAT MIGHT BE- AT.
BECAUSE THIS THIS REALLY. IS IT
IS A IS A GOOD WAY TO TAKE
LEGACY FINDS AND REPURPOSE THEM
WE MAY WANT TO CONSIDER LOOKING
AT ALL THAT. IT HOUSING-
RESOURCES THE GO OUT FROM FROM-
FROM EIGHT CD AND FIGURE OUT IF
THERE'S A WAY FOR US TO
STREAMLINE THEM INTO YOUR
CATEGORIES MEAN. REPHRASE THAT
TO STREAMLINED THEM SO THAT YOU
COULD TAKE ALL THE FORMER
HOUSING AND PUT HIM IN THE ONE
PROGRAM TAKE THAT THAT TRANSIT
AND THE MULTI FAMILY AND PUT
HIM IN TO WONDER OR- AND- IN
THAT WOULD TAKE LEGISLATION
OBVIOUSLY AND AS THE- SENATE
CONTINUES TO WORK ON A HOUSING.
PACKAGE THAT MAY BE ONE OF THE
THINGS WE CAN LOOK AT. AND WHAT
THE PURPOSE. OF WHICH IS TO IS
TO STREAMLINE PROCESSES TO
REDUCE THE AMOUNT OF WORK THAT
STAFF HAS TO DO TO FIGURE OUT
IF THE ROUND PEG FITS THE
SQUARE- HOLE AND- AND- SO I PUT
THAT OUT THERE BECAUSE I KNOW.
AS I'VE TALKED TO SOME OF THE-
THE FOR PROFIT AND THE
NONPROFIT DEVELOPERS. IS THEY
REALLY ARE LOOKING HOW TO MAKE
THINGS WORK AND IF IT WAS A
BROADER CATEGORY IT MIGHT BE A-
LITTLE BIT EASIER. TO GET ROLL
THE FUNDS OUT AND GET-
PRODUCTION MOVING I GUESS IS
THE BEST WAY TO PUT IT SO I PUT
THAT OUT THERE THAT'S NOT
ANYWHERE ON THE PLAN BUT I LIKE
THE WAY THAT. THAT YOU
SUGGESTED USING TAKING THESE
LEGACY FUNDS AND INSTEAD OF
HAVING THEM IN A FUND THAT- YOU
KNOW IT'S OLD. AND WE KEEP WEEK
WE CAN REPURPOSE SOME AND I'M-
IT OCCURRED TO ME WE MIGHT WANT
TO. LOOK A LITTLE BIT BRIGHTER
WILL LOOK AT IT TOO BUT YOU
KNOW THE PROGRAMS BETTER AND
MAYBE COULD MAKE SOME
SUGGESTIONS FOR US IF YOU'RE
LOOKING FOR TO WORKING WITH
YOU. VERY GOOD OKAY THAT'S NOT
A HOLD OPEN- THAT THAT
CONCLUDES OUR HEARING FOR
TODAY- I WANT TO SEE IF THERE'S
ANYONE WHO WHO JUST WANTS TO
MAKE UP PUBLIC COMMENT. ON ON
ON ANYTHING. I DON'T SEE ANY
MOVEMENT WHICH IS ALWAYS GOOD-
WE'VE BEEN- EXPEDITIOUS AND I
APPRECIATE THAT THAT TESTIMONY
HERE TODAY IT'S BEEN VERY
HELPFUL I THINK. TO ASK SO THAT
CONCLUDES OUR HEARING AND WE
ARE IN RECESS THANK YOU.